What the hell was that?
Useless against it!
U-U-Useless against it!
Oh, it's over.
Wait, there's one part at the very beginning of this that makes me want to be like...
I want a remix of this song.
But like, you know, like old school remix song.
Where it's just like...
Boop-boop-boop-boop!
That's somebody's scream.
She says...
If you don't think of something, I'm gonna die here!
If you don't think of something, if you don't think of something, if you don't think of something, I'm gonna die!
Die!
D-D-D-D-D-D-Die here!
Nice to keep you!
Remembership...
Hello everybody!
Welcome back, sir and ma'am!
Hello... Oh, here we go.
Here we go!
B-b-b-b-b-remix!
Yeah, yeah, let's just do this.
Oh that's what it is.
I'm gonna die if you don't think of something quick.
Quick, quick, quick, quick, I'm gonna die if you don't think of something quick.
Dodge left, do, do, do, dodge left.
Number one, number two.
I'm gonna die here if you don't think of something quick.
Oh, oh, oh.
These are all spoilers!
These are all spoilers.
Usually, Lurk, we saw a clip of you singing Bing Bong and I was like, you sing, give it a go, Lurk.
Waaa!
Thank you, Viking Froggy.
Bing, bing bong.
Bing bing, bing bing bong.
I said come on.
Wait, I don't get that one.
It would go so hard!
Hire me, Sony!
Anyways guys, welcome back to Lifeline Voice Action Adventure!
And this should be the last time I guess we play this because I'm hoping...
I'm gonna... well, not hoping.
We'll finish today.
Unless I get stuck in a room for like 5 hours.
That would be pretty... that would be pretty pathetic on my part.
Somebody's got a lot of energy today.
No, this is normal, I think.
I am finishing my lunch though.
I made some Indomie which I haven't had in a long, long time.
But I was like, oh gosh, I should eat something real fast.
And I have eggs and I don't want them to go bad, you know.
So I was like, I'm gonna have Indomie.
I don't eat...
I'm back now.
Good night.
Good night!
Can we have some?
You want some?
It's pretty normal.
I actually messed up my egg.
I messed it up pretty bad.
Especially since how pricey they are now.
Exactly!
That's why I was like, oh my gosh.
I can't let my eggs go bad.
Because they cost so much!
They're so pricey.
What kind of egg?
Sunnyside-o?
Thank you for the five gifted!
Happy Monday!
I hope Ryo actually listens for once.
What's bonus?
I just noticed this.
Do I not have any bonuses?
I think we're this one.
Let's see what we got.
Ostrich eggs.
I've never had anything other than a chicken egg, I think.
Number of chips.
11 out of 16!
We're killing it, you guys!
Tutorial word jumble.
Complete the phrases.
The calc.
What's word jumble?
Word jumble.
Wait, what is this?
Word jumble?
Not the calc.
That wouldn't let me play...
Rearrange the letters on the screen to make a word and speak the word before time runs out.
You get three guesses per question.
The faster you answer, the higher the score.
There are 20 jumbles in each game.
Oh, I'm not going to do...
This is like my worst nightmare.
Ready?
Start.
Ick.
Sick.
Click.
Kick.
One.
Time's up.
Bad.
Dead.
Oh wait, dead.
How do I talk...
Dead.
Good.
I did it.
I forgot how to talk.
Ok, good.
Toba.
Boba.
Bad.
Bato.
Sock.
What?
Type them.
Type.
My type.
Payment.
Empty.
Bad.
Sound.
Excellent.
That one was so easy.
Squirrel.
Wait, pearl.
No.
Seal.
Five.
Four.
Reels.
Two.
One.
Time's up.
Bad.
Laser.
USB mic.
No.
Five.
Four.
Three.
Two.
One.
Time's up.
Music.
Oxygen.
Unbelievable.
Egg.
Ugly.
Gauge.
Hoses.
Hose.
Time's up.
Shoes.
What?
Lamein.
Oh my gosh.
Horse?
Five.
Four.
Three.
Two.
Horses.
Time's up.
Shower.
What?
Five.
Four.
Three.
Two.
One.
Time's up.
Pillow.
Five.
Four.
Three.
Two.
One.
Good.
Four.
Three.
Two.
One.
Time's up.
Forward.
Paramedic.
Shit.
Power...
Four.
Three.
Two.
One.
Time's up.
Approach.
Crochet.
Oh.
Crocket.
Five.
Four.
Three.
Two.
One.
Rocket.
No!
Three.
Two.
One.
Don't.
No!
That's literally what I'm eating!
Guys, I have like... So when I do those types of puzzles...
I don't have that thing where you...
Where you can't imagine things.
Like say someone's like, picture an apple.
Some people can't picture an apple in their head.
But I only have that when it comes to words.
I literally only see the word that is spelled out.
Even if it's not a real word.
You can't picture the apple?
Only
see what is there.
Let's try one more time.
This is our warm up, everybody.
Alright.
Okay, we're gonna beat our high score.
We got this.
Back.
Yeah!
Hade.
Five.
Four.
Three.
Two.
One.
Head!
No!
Duck.
I got it, I got it, I got it.
Slot.
Tossel?
Lost!
Lampy.
Lam...
Mouthy.
Flame.
Can't.
I can't.
Tank.
Oh!
Disrespect.
Oh.
Dire...
Fo...
Spider!
Careful.
Fookie.
What the?
This is not a real word.
So...
Toes.
What?
The...
Hotel.
Being.
Oh, I got it, I got it, I got it.
Oh my gosh.
Drink.
Oh, we are beating our high score for real.
Oh, maybe not.
Indecision, indecision.
Inside!
Question.
Yeah!
Corpse.
Oh my god, that was real!
Gallons.
Oh,
I thought it...I didn't realize it didn't change at first.
I was like, it was gallons!
Oops.
Parents.
Just preordered MGS Delta.
Yeah!
I don't know!
Oh my god.
Demolish.
These are impossible.
To...
Optic.
Action!
Crow.
Oh, wait, that's not a W.
Recover!
Oh my god, I got it!
Oh my god, I got...wow.
No more.
My print hurts.
Oh yeah!
The difference variance is wild.
Nucky, thanks for the gift!
Oh yeah!
There was the other thing too.
Complete the phrases.
We got this.
I can't believe I missed ghost.
Oh.
Is this like a Mad Libs?
A famous phrase?
Oh no.
Wait, one more.
It's a famous phrase?
OK.
How famous are these phrases?
Fire.
What?
That's what I said.
If at first you don't succeed.
Bliss.
Christmas comes...once?
Is that a famous saying?
Exchange is real.
A woman's boob.
Money is...Root!
Bed?
It is...funny.
Old.
Make...blank all the honey in the fly...what?
Money?
Make money, honey.
Speak when you are...spoken.
Knife?
Oh.
Die.
Yes?
Logs.
Ignorance of the law...
Many hands make light...
Figures.
Work.
I've never heard that one.
Trust is the...opposite.
Dying.
Oh my god!
Thanks for the 50 gifted!
Ill weeds.
Thank you so much for the 50!
Thank you!
I don't know it.
A bully is always a piece of shit.
Probably like top score.
True, yeah.
It should have been counted points anyway.
Alright, shall we get into the game now?
Stop please!
I've already been tortured enough!
Yeah, world record everybody.
On complete the phrase.
So you're saying you wouldn't notice any hidden meaning in the name about someone owning a lot of stocks...
I did it!
I literally...That's why those kinds of things...
Those kinds of wordplay gets me.
Because I literally only see what is written until I say it out loud.
But not always either.
This is the game.
I wonder if there is a task bot that can nail every word.
Probably, right?
It's no fun though.
It's no fun!
Alright, we're at 11 out of 16 chips.
I wonder if we get the calc once we get all 16 chips.
Hello, real.
It's been a minute.
Get up.
I have to remember what controls are.
I think it's really just circle and then this.
Alright.
What were we doing?
We were headed to...
Actually, let's...consultation.
Let's get some help.
Quiet, real.
You're also so close.
What to do?
No!
Consultation.
Help me, real.
Thank you so much for the 5 gifted.
Thank you.
Let's see.
What should we do?
Yeah.
It will be.
For you.
Not me.
I'm safe and sound in my own room.
Bald!
Welcome to membership.
It will forever be the cutest...
Stop!
The H gods!
Sounds awesome.
Wait, so what are we doing then?
That's not what we should do.
That's what you should do.
Avoid the robot.
No, not robot.
Sorry.
Avoid the monster.
Oh wait, there's more about here.
No, tell me about yourself.
She has no patience.
Consultation.
Yeah, the sexy alien lady.
Okay, what would you like to know about?
Tell me about yourself.
I'm half German and half Japanese.
My age, measurements and hobbies are my business.
I didn't ask for that.
Occupation?
Waitress.
Will that do?
Okay.
How far away are you?
I bet there's something else.
Just ask her, yeah.
Hang in there just a little while longer, okay?
Okay.
That's her actually addressing me, the player, trying to get through this game.
Naomi wasn't there.
She doesn't care about...
What should we do?
That humanoid monster that was in the warehouse?
She's actually choosing to ignore Naomi.
That might be the end.
She might be perfect.
Rio is truly a single-celled organism.
Just like I put in the title of the stream today.
Naomi wasn't there.
She wasn't at the receiving port.
But don't let it bring you down.
She's gotta be waiting patiently somewhere for rescue.
Naomi.
Oh yeah, Japanese pronunciation, right?
Tell me what you're looking for.
She's so secretive.
What if she's the bad guy?
Let's see.
That alien earlier.
Yeah.
So I can't see myself defeating it.
Yeah, why is the waitress looking for secret things?
Exactly.
Ask her about Aqua.
Like the idol group.
I lost my gallons to this H-God.
What is a gallons?
I hope you find it.
Wait, what was that one again?
Gallons.
Signal.
Okay.
Let's go somewhere.
We are headed to...
We just saved, so we're headed to...
Go to Area C.
Run.
Yes.
Bogo is minted.
Things are 8 months.
Area C...
I guess that's correct.
Oh no!
Oh God.
That shouldn't... Wait.
What the heck?
Strafe.
Left stomach.
Enemy 2.
Stomach.
Mouth.
Run.
Enemy 1.
Mouth.
Reload.
Or that too.
That works.
What did we say?
Strafe.
No.
Run.
Isn't it... Oh wait.
It's flee, right?
It's flee.
I remember now.
Mouth.
Strafe.
It's not doing anything.
Left stomach.
Reload.
Flee.
There we go.
Okay, nice.
Left stomach.
Can't see it.
Right stomach.
Why is it so...
Beefy.
Mouth.
Tail.
Body.
It's dodging everything.
Flee.
Strafe.
Oh nice, nice, nice.
Yeah, reload, reload.
Strafe.
I don't think she hit a single one.
Oh that works too, actually.
Oh, hinder the legs.
Okay.
Left stomach.
Nope.
Oh, flee.
Hind leg.
Tail.
Left stomach.
Oh nice.
Flee.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Strafe.
Flee.
No survival instincts.
Red stomach.
Reload.
Oh god.
Oh, run.
Flee.
Mouth.
Oh my god.
Flee.
Oh no, no, no.
Run.
Recover.
Please recover.
Okay, good, good, good.
Red stomach.
Oh my god, I didn't even notice that she was out of bullets.
Flee.
Run.
Red stomach.
Flee.
Ah, flee.
Red stomach.
Oh my god.
Body.
Red stomach.
Oh my god, we got it.
Yeah, I wonder whose fault that is that we couldn't move on any faster.
Huh, Rio?
My goodness gracious.
This is the final boss.
Okay.
I always have to remember not to scream at her because she just...
I try, I like, imagine the energy of the vibe, but I'm just like, flee!
Flee!
Go to area C.
There's a guy here, right?
Oh, nope.
Okay.
Go to area B.
Hell yeah.
Is she running?
Oh, there's nothing here either?
There's really nothing here?
Wait, what do you see?
Okay.
Oh,
maybe we explode it.
Okay.
Yeah, try it.
Oh, stand back.
Maybe?
Stand back.
Okay.
John, thanks for three bullets.
Yeah, go launch her.
Does she always have a neck bow?
I don't.
She's kind of crazy.
She is a little crazy.
But we appreciate...
Oh my god.
Rio.
Rio!
Oh my god.
Sure.
Red.
Blue.
Green.
Yeah...
Yes.
I don't have faith in you, Rio!
What do I... Do I just say blue or do I just say green to tell her to switch?
Alright, she's going nice and slow.
Slow and... I think you can...
Blue.
Red.
Okay, some are wobbly and if they're wobbly I have to tell her to get off too.
Blue.
Blue!
Oh my god.
Green!
Okay.
Blue!
Wait, how do I... Here?
Red.
Blue.
Four months!
I hope I said your name right.
Sorry if I didn't.
Imagine the amount of happy relationships you could ruin if this game had a co-op multiplayer.
Oh god, no please.
Let's see.
So we're going to...
Go to Area A.
I...
What are you supposed to do there?
I don't actually get it.
Oh, tongue twister.
Stop!
Oh, too late.
It's okay, maybe.
I should have probably saved after that one guy, huh?
I'm sorry!
Okay.
Is that one wobbly?
Blue!
Does she get hurt when she does this?
Tongue twisters.
How do I do the tongue twisters again?
Let's see.
Oh shoot, I forgot to pull it up on my phone.
Oh, she sells.
She sells.
Yeah.
Yes.
Oh my god, life.
Lying tongue twister.
Pick up six pick up sticks quickly.
Okay, where are they?
Oh my god.
Oh no, I'm not ready.
Please, no real, please no.
No!
Okay, okay, that one's not bad.
Okay, I got it, I got it.
Sheep shouldn't sleep in a shack.
Sheep should sleep in a shed.
Okay, okay, I got, I got the, I got the guide.
Oh no, I never do this one right.
I never do this one right.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
Ah!
I never get that one.
I don't know why.
She sells.
Yes.
And I didn't get the beginning wrong.
I said I saw Esau kissing Kate.
Okay.
Around the rugged rocks the ragged rascal ran.
We did this one.
Sheep shouldn't sleep in a shack.
Sheep should sleep in a shed.
Yeah.
Please no Esau, I saw Esau.
Ah!
A woodchuck could chuck wood.
A woodchuck would chuck as much as he could chuck if a woodchuck could.
Good.
How much wood would a woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck could chuck wood?
A woodchuck would chuck as much as it could chuck if a woodchuck could.
Yay!
Oh my gosh.
Let's do it one more time and then we'll go heal.
Or, I'm sorry, save.
She sells.
It's impressive.
Yes.
Thank you.
Rubber baby buggy bumpers.
Okay.
Fuzzy wuzzy was a bear.
Fuzzy wuzzy had no hair.
Fuzzy wuzzy wasn't fuzzy wuzzy, was it?
Fuzzy wuzzy was a bear.
Fuzzy wuzzy had no hair.
Fuzzy wuzzy wasn't fuzzy wuzzy.
Yeah!
I'm gonna go slow with this one.
I saw Esaw kissing Kate.
Kate saw I saw Esaw.
Esaw saw that I saw Kate.
And Kate saw I saw Esaw.
Ever!
I never get it!
It never registers that one.
She sells.
Yes.
Maybe I have to go fast maybe.
I saw she saw she saw saw.
I saw I saw I saw I saw.
You saw I saw you saw.
Kate saw I saw I saw.
What was it?
Around the rugged rocks, the rascal ran.
Oh, I forgot to say the ragged rascal.
Oops.
She sells her seashells to the shore.
Thanks Phoenix!
Thanks for nine months.
She sells seashells on the seashore.
Seashells she sells are seashells she is sure.
That one's hard.
Yeah, don't say it.
Betty Batter had some butter, but she said this butter's bitter.
If I bake this bitter butter, then it would make my batter bitter.
Yeah, I got this one.
Betty Batter had some butter, but she said this butter's bitter.
If I bake this bitter butter, then it would make my batter bitter.
Yeah!
Oh, thank goodness.
In British.
Go to Area C.
Wait, what?
Oh.
Go to Area B.
No, no, no!
Go to Area...
Stop!
Walking real!
Full health, I know.
Not for long though.
Blue.
Red.
Yes.
Okay, so she doesn't just walk off the ledge.
That's good to know.
Real walk.
Forward.
Blue.
Green.
Yeah, she makes such a stink about it until...
Blue.
So stupid.
She's such a joke.
I saw PTSD for being stuck on this part for days.
This is where many people end up quitting the game to preserve their sanity.
Wait, what do you mean by that, Nicholas?
Like this...
Go to Area B.
What?
I'm not saying Area A.
What is the... What am I supposed to do here?
But actually though... Because when we get to that part...
There's only red... Oh yeah, only red and green.
Can she jump that far?
I doubt it.
Jump jump pose.
Green then red.
Blue.
You can jump that far?
Okay, we'll try it.
Red.
Forward.
Blue.
Okay, let's try.
Green.
I have to be careful with blue.
I think maybe my mic is like...
Blue.
You dumbass bitch!
God dammit Rio!
Blue!
We were so close the first time.
Go to Area A.
Run.
Blue.
I don't think left right works because she told me to say the colors.
Actually though, I did try saying right.
Or she thought I said right at one point.
But it's her left and her right.
Blue.
Maybe she's color blind.
Red.
Walk.
She might be color blind.
Blue.
Nice.
That was smooth.
Green.
Nice.
Blue.
Green.
Red.
She really does make it.
Holy moly!
Oh my gosh we made it!
Oh what was that?
What was that?
No there's more?
There's more and there's steam!
Oh my gosh.
No!
Green.
Oh my gosh.
Are you kidding me?
Blue.
Blue!
Oh my gosh.
Lee is real.
Please walk.
Go to Area D.
Maybe there's something down there that like...
Maybe we can just skip all of this, right?
We go through Area D and we skip all this funny business.
It's funny every time.
Welcome back to Goose Dumpster!
There's a health kit though.
It was worth.
Hello again.
Minto.
If Rio was walking through a park it was a different thing.
No!
Rio wouldn't do anything.
Run.
Oh my god.
Oh no, this is gonna be so hellish.
This really is Goose Dumps Room 2.0.
No, please god.
Please god, please.
Please, please.
Please, please, please.
Don't do this Rio.
Green.
Please, please, please.
I'm gonna...
It's about to go, yeah.
Walk.
Go to Area C.
I think I waited too long on that one.
I did say blue though.
I did say blue.
Rio, I'm going to murder you.
Why can't she jump forward?
Green.
Walk.
What if I say...
Red.
Blue.
Stop.
Ok, hold on.
Ok.
And then the next one.
This one.
Walk.
Stop.
Green.
We were doing so well man.
We were doing so well.
It's all Rio's fault.
She sells.
Rio's family guy death pose.
The fact she doesn't even attempt to like... You know how most people...
Yes.
Most people like put their arms out when they're trying to protect their bodies, you know.
But she just falls flat on her face.
Rubber baby buggy bumpers.
She just falls like a two year old.
She sells.
She sells seashells on the seashore.
Seashells she sells are our seashells she is sure.
Ok.
No song.
If I bake this bitter butter it would make my batter bitter.
Yeah.
I'm a rap queen.
You're welcome.
Ok yeah you did.
Ok.
What is it?
Go to area C.
We were doing so well this last one.
I'm so sad.
After two hours we couldn't get past this.
No.
I believe in us.
Green.
Nice.
Stop.
Blue.
Walk.
Walk faster.
You're scaring me.
You're making me nervous.
Red.
Stop.
Blue.
Oh my god.
Which one is the... Ok so it's that one first.
Walk.
Stop.
Your little toes got burnt Rio.
Did your toes get burnt Rio?
Do you need someone to kiss them?
Do you need someone to suckle them?
Do you need someone to make them feel better Rio?
Go to area C.
Stop.
I'm already... It's not even an hour into the stream guys.
I'm so... It's so over for me.
Green.
It's so over for me.
Blue.
Walk faster please.
You're scaring me.
Stop.
Walk.
Area C.
Run.
What was she trying to say about the ceiling?
Use your eyes Rio.
It's not my fault.
What do you mean guide you properly?
We found the room.
Green.
We really did.
I really... I really cursed myself with that didn't I?
Blue.
Stop.
Walk.
Yep.
Please walk faster.
You're scaring me.
Stop.
Walk.
Green.
Red.
Stop.
These ones are like at the same time.
Blue.
Walk.
Yeah.
Crouch?
I don't know.
What do you want me to do?
Green.
Walk.
Stop.
Let's see how this one works.
Walk.
Stop.
No we're not going to make it.
Walk.
Red.
Oh shit.
I can't tell by depth perception you guys.
I think it's green.
I think we go all the way to the end of the green and then we... green.
Walk.
Red.
Blue.
Oh my god girl.
Take a step forward.
What's wrong with you?
You!
Oh my god!
I can't believe she just...imagine if we had fallen off right there on the final one.
I broke her.
This girl is unbelievable.
We did it!
I can't go back now.
Let's move on.
You chose...when she makes her own decision she gets mad at me.
She's like I can't do it now.
I can't go back now.
Let's see.
How many...okay we have two heal capsules.
And two launcher grenades.
Let's go to waiting room.
There might be a save in there.
I know we'll probably get ambushed though, sadly.
I don't want to die.
Please don't make me go through it again.
Please game.
Be kind game.
Please.
Please be kind game.
I'm scared.
Wait, who is that?
Wait, is that the reporter you were trying to find before?
Yeah, because she was trying to find a reporter lady.
If only she was alive.
She's human.
Hello.
Okay.
August 8th.
Oh, I found it.
I found it.
Red disc.
No, no.
Oh my god.
Blue star.
No, that's...
Red disc with blue star.
No, no, no.
Red disc, blue star.
Blue star, red disc.
She keeps picking up the same one over and over again.
No.
Mario, stop that one.
Blue star, red box.
Red cover.
Red cover, blue star.
All she hears is one thing.
She only...
Red with blue star.
Oh my god.
Goodness gracious.
This is so fun.
Mario, you have no business.
It's right here.
I'm going to eat while she watches.
Hello, manager.
Isn't that what we...
Yeah.
Wait, so you are literally here as a normal person?
The blue ball.
What?
I thought I left out when the same reporter came aboard to cover the opening ceremony.
I figured I could ask her.
Why would she know?
She was just...
Now you know how I feel working with you.
The blurb.
Your mom.
Are you serious?
No way.
Captain.
I don't know.
Why don't you think of it?
I can't believe that she actually has a response for your mom.
I can't believe it.
Naomi.
And it's not giving me the option...
It's not giving me the option to go through my list of people.
Does anybody else know?
Naomi.
I know.
Gustav.
Oh, what was the friend?
Who?
Who is Alan Honda?
Jonathan.
No.
Am I going to get a game over with this?
I'm scared.
I'm actually scared.
I don't want to get a game over.
I don't know.
Look it up in a walkthrough.
Everybody is saying the worst things ever.
Hold on.
I'm going to the walkthrough.
I'm scared.
I have no idea and it's not giving me an option to...
Hold on.
Walkthrough.
Equipment.
Where are we?
A guest room.
No, we are past that.
We are past the restroom, the moon suite.
We are in the waiting room.
The waiting room.
Exhibit room.
What is that?
Laboratory.
We are not there yet.
Waiting room.
Who should we ask?
Tell her the name of anyone you've met and she will give you a response.
But the correct reply is Gino.
Who the hell is Gino?
Gino.
Who?
Glad we are all in agreement.
Oh yeah baby.
Yes.
The blue ball.
Please talk.
She is being so edgy.
What is it?
Then tell me.
Tell me.
You got it dude.
Alright, our girlfriend.
Yeah, we got to get Naomi.
Oh my goodness, there is a save.
Save point.
Oh, it feels so good.
Oh my gosh, it feels so good.
Yeah, yeah baby.
So she did not tell us what the blue ball is.
She did not tell us about the blue ball, but that's okay.
Yay!
Oh joyous day indeed.
I feel such relief.
Right now you guys don't even know.
Alright, let's check.
We got a lot of stuff in here.
Let's check.
Vending machine.
What the?
The vending machine.
Okay.
That was weird.
Oh gosh, there is so much here.
Plant.
Leafy house plant.
Check under couch.
Yeah.
Rio is not our girlfriend.
I don't want Rio to be our girlfriend.
I don't want this.
Check corpse.
Yeah.
Check Helen's corpse.
Check other corpse.
Logan, thank you so much for the five gifts.
Thank you.
Check camera.
Yeah, what else would I be talking about?
Seriously?
Really?
Check video camera.
Yeah.
We got another chip.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Are we sure there is nothing in this corpse?
How am I supposed to name this one?
Check vending machine.
Check left side of vending machine.
Mr. Obese, thanks for the ten gifts.
Check yellow corpse.
I thought she went...
Before she finished, I thought she meant like...
His guts went everywhere.
Damn.
Check CDs.
It's just news footage.
We won't be needing this disc.
What?
Year is 2030 and they are using discs?
Crazy.
What should I say for the vending machine?
CDs.
Stop.
Oh yeah.
Check left vending machine slot.
It's the same as the one in the security room.
Oh yeah, let's just say...
Vending machine slots.
Stop, please.
I don't know how to...
That was like literally the beginning of the game.
It's not a coin slot.
Tray?
Oh yeah.
Check vending machine tray.
It's the same as the one in the security room.
Oh dispenser.
Dispenser.
You guys are genius.
Check left dispenser.
Yundoki did an amazing job no matter what.
Oh thank you Magister.
Thank you, I appreciate it.
Check right dispenser.
Useless.
Alrighty.
We got everything here.
Check window.
I don't think there was anything for the vacuum.
It wasn't highlighted.
It's round!
Take that!
Take that non-believers!
Check table.
The table.
We're not even in space.
Check business center.
What is a business center?
Thank you for the good times Minto.
Thanks Lembas!
Your profile picture is so nostalgic.
Check printer.
No.
Stop.
Go to business center.
Is it maybe a copier?
Printer?
Copier.
Check copier.
Okay, it is copier.
Check right copier.
We got it.
Oh look.
There is a document in it.
Secrets?
Read a document.
Which copier do you mean?
Take document.
Yep, it's just ordinary everyday copier paper.
Uncertified hamster!
Happy birthday!
Hoping you will survive Gustav's torture room part 3.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
What do you mean?
Answer the question before I sing you happy birthday!
Hamster!
Open tray.
What am I to open?
No, I don't think that works.
Check document.
Yep, it's just ordinary everyday copier paper.
Make a copy gives you a new command.
Really?
Make a copy.
Which copier do you mean?
Make a copy right copier.
Make a copy?
Ok, I'll press the button.
She's going to do it.
Hey, something came out.
Jump this red light.
Wait, what?
Jump?
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday Uncertified Hamster!
Happy birthday!
I was referring to Rio always thinking you said stop when you said Gustavo.
Gotcha!
Out of service.
Midsize copier.
Copy fax and TV functions.
What is that thing on the right?
Check phone.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Stop.
Business center.
What is it?
Alarm?
Alarm.
Well, I still have my health.
Looks like an ATM, I don't think.
That's... I don't know.
Looks like a key...
Key card reader.
Do you mean that?
Key box!
Check key box.
The observatory restaurant's key is in here, but this is locked.
Oh...
It is locked.
I got it.
That's me playing the game.
Not Honkai!
What is that?
Can you open it, Operator?
Joe Mama.
Please state your full name.
It has to be the full name, remember?
I wish we had a...
a relationship chart.
Who is it supposed to be?
I don't think it's Jonathan or Gustav.
I sure hope it's not Gustav.
Control section.
I don't think it's them.
I'm gonna actually...
I'm gonna look this up.
I'm sorry, guys.
If it's any people, I don't know names.
Oh my gosh!
Wait, it is Jonathan Turner!
Wait.
You have to...
The guide says basically you have to know the manager's name to get in, which is the correct answer.
Thanks to looking in the employee IDs is Jon...
Where does it say that?
Did I miss it?
It doesn't...
It literally doesn't say that at all.
It doesn't say that he is the manager.
Anywhere.
Is he actually watching me?
Key box.
Control system document.
Wait, where?
Night vision...
I guess the administrator is there.
I guess that.
Key...
Sorry, I forgot what it was called.
I forgot what it was called.
Nemotaku!
Welcome to Rainbow Chef.
Thank you.
Let's do it.
Jonathan...
Stop talking.
Jonathan Turner.
Can you send a greeting to the Wawa Nation?
Let's go Wawa Nation!
Were we trying to?
Save point.
Were we trying to get in there?
I don't know.
We haven't...
Spoilers.
I eat while it saves.
Oh no!
I don't remember why I saved on a previous one before, but...
Whoopsie.
Oopsie.
Alright.
We have looked at everything in here.
So...
Hallway.
OK.
If I get a bad ending, it's what she deserves.
I love...
What did I say?
Real.
But she understood that somehow.
Oh, we fought in here before.
What if I...
Elevator.
We got ambushed in here before, right?
And we are getting ambushed again!
No way!
Niki!
Head.
Seriously?
Flee.
Guard.
Strafe.
Flee.
Where is it?
Oh my god, still?
Enemy one.
How the hell?
Flee.
Girl, you need to run further.
Seriously.
Flee.
This thing is so annoying.
Enemy one.
Flee.
Eye.
Enemy one.
Flee.
Oh, she's reloading.
Eye.
Oh
my god, when it's going invisible, it can't get shot at.
Really?
Flee.
Oopsie.
Eye.
Flee.
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Flee.
Why didn't you run?
You said yes.
You said yes, why didn't you run?
Oh my gosh, at least we got through it.
I didn't want to restart.
Even though I used a health, that's okay.
We still have two, I think, left?
Wait.
Yeah.
Elevator hall.
She did jump.
I wonder if I could've jumped to avoid the attack.
Okay.
What does sexy pose do?
Do a sexy pose.
That's what it does.
Observatory restaurant.
What's gunslinger style?
Is that a real thing?
Does that work on the enemies?
It could.
Oh my gosh, wait.
This looks highly unstable for someone who breathes oxygen.
I do.
Yes.
This is where the party was.
Yeah.
Okay.
How did I get to where I was?
I'll come.
And get ambushed.
Oh, there's a save point.
Save point.
No, no.
What are you talking about?
Look at what?
The fire?
Seriously?
That didn't sound good.
What was that?
Yeah, what was that?
No, no, no.
No, we're gonna...
We're gonna get ambushed.
I didn't get to save.
No, please.
Ryo, don't investigate.
Please let me...
Please let me save first.
Ryo, no.
Ryo, don't do it.
Save.
Save point.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Run.
Maybe it was...
I feel like...
Well, no.
I was gonna say, I feel like they don't usually give save points in rooms where you get attacked.
But that is...
100% false.
Hot dog.
I think the combat has some good ideas.
Like the use of weak points.
It's just ruined by the voice activated controls.
Yeah, pretty much.
No,
but like...
It's also because it's so slow.
When I'm trying to...
Like...
Saying dodge doesn't...
I would have to like time everything so perfectly.
To be able to dodge stuff.
Because I have to do the input and then she has to listen to me.
And then do it.
It's like a three-step system.
Rather than just if I were to press a button and dodge.
It's like...
I would...
I have to think literally three steps ahead.
Of what the enemy is doing.
To...
To be able to say dodge.
And she actually register it.
And it actually works.
And the enemy actually properly did the attack that I was thinking of.
This is how chat feels back saying sometimes.
No, I don't think so.
VIP seat one.
Nevermind.
Can we blast it?
Blast it.
With the grenade.
You have the grenade.
You literally...
You picked that up.
Machine gun.
I don't know.
Launcher grenade.
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's so loud.
I don't think that's really safe to do in a room that is...
Look at the glass on the windows.
It's so scary.
Oh gosh.
Oh my god.
VIP seat one.
This is so scary.
Anything here?
Okay.
VIP seat two.
She's listening so well.
A chip.
Chip, chip, chip, chip.
This game would be a bit better if...
It would feel a bit better if Rio were like a robot.
Yeah, true.
True, I do agree.
Everything is better with robots.
VIP seat three.
Can you shoot the window?
Shoot window.
I guess not.
Letter.
Yup.
Menu.
Check menu.
Dirty.
Check lamp.
The lamp.
Lamp.
Stop.
VIP seat three.
What is that?
Flower?
Is it a flower?
Flower.
Yeah, what is that?
What is that?
Floor lamp.
Check floor lamp.
This is already broken.
We got a new command though.
It's in...
No, no, no.
How do I...
Choose to believe she is cursed by a genie and gave up her executive function to gain the power of healing via limb rigs and tongue twisters.
Check lamp shade.
Are you talking about that?
Yeah.
Check inside floor lamp.
That's broken.
No.
Check floor lamp shade.
Are you talking about that?
Oh no.
This is like the bed all over again.
Oh my god.
Look in lamp.
That's broken.
Oh gosh.
Top of lamp.
Wine or champagne.
It's too dirty to tell what it is.
Check inside floor lamp.
That's broken.
I don't think I can tip it over.
I don't think...
Tip over lamp.
I tried checking the top.
Check top of floor lamp.
Yeah.
Oh.
What is she...
Is she breaking it?
Oh.
She broke it?
She really broke it.
We are in champagne.
Champagne.
I'll leave it to you?
Wait.
Are we...
Are we giving her sentience?
No way.
No.
You've got grave reflexes.
I'll leave it to you?
Wait.
What is this?
In battle.
Is it auto fight?
No way.
Oh my gosh.
Consultation.
Check what?
Save point.
The save point.
Okay.
We'll put her in control and see how it works.
Run.
Yes.
Spin gun.
How she can become revolver Rio?
She can.
I don't think you can sexy pose in battle.
The game is flawed clearly.
For denying us that access.
You can see it in the things that they...
The commands that show when is allowed at what time.
I know it's outrageous, right?
Absolutely outrageous.
Let me direct the game next.
I'll give the people what they want.
Sexy pose in all battles.
It's an automatic win.
Let's see.
What else is in here?
Oh, VIP.
VIP seat 4.
Run.
Yes.
Wait, is this also blocked?
Oh no.
We are left...
I don't have enough...
Grenade launchers.
Uh-oh.
We only have one more and we have two panels that it wants us to break.
I feel like the other one is gonna be an ambush.
I just saved.
So let's do this.
We'll do the other one.
If it's an ambush, I just...
We'll test out the auto battle.
Or I could die, whichever.
And then we could...
Reload and then try this one.
Yeah, we'll save scum a little bit.
So...
What was it?
Section 2?
Section 2.
Yeah, let's explore the timeline.
Yeah, we're gonna...
Big brain time.
It wasn't... Wait, wait, wait.
Panel.
Stop.
How do I get to that panel right there?
Is that...
Chandelier?
Chandelier.
I'm...
Gonna swing...
From the chandelier.
Grenade.
Yeah.
I'm...
Gonna live...
Like tomorrow doesn't exist.
Wait, there's a second panel?
That was the last...
There's more...
We need 2 more?
We need 3 more technically.
How am I supposed to get more?
Okay, let's check...
Let's go check section...
We still have section 3, 1 and 2.
There might be some in there.
Section 2.
No way they'd soft lock you.
No, because we just got 2 more.
Right.
What?
I don't know.
Oh my god.
Are you kidding me?
I'll leave it to you.
Look at her go.
She hasn't landed one hit.
Left stomach.
Nice.
Run!
Please.
Left stomach.
Reload.
I don't think she's very good you guys.
Left stomach.
Left... Right stomach.
Right stomach.
Red stomach.
Please.
Oh my god, she's blocked.
Red stomach.
Please.
Enemy 2.
Mouth.
I'll leave it to you.
She's got this.
Maybe not.
Oh god.
I'll leave it to you.
Run!
Red stomach.
Enemy 2.
Mouth.
Stomach.
Reload.
Enemy 1.
Red stomach.
Red...
Flee!
Jump!
Red stomach.
Flee.
That was close.
She does command sometimes, but I'm not even finished talking.
I didn't talk... I didn't say anything.
Red stomach.
Hind leg.
Tail.
Red stomach.
Flee.
Hind leg.
Red stomach.
Tail.
Mouth!
Red stomach!
Oh, flee!
Mouth!
Oh my gosh, she's reloading.
Red stomach!
No!
Mouth!
Red stomach!
Stomach!
Mouth!
Oh, stomach!
Stomach!
Low kick!
Oh my god, stomach!
Oh my god, if you die here...
Stomach!
Alright guys...
Time for some tongue twisters.
Me too!
Wait, what is this?
Oh, it gave another launcher!
Launcher!
We actually had to do that.
Oh my god.
Once you lock onto a part you can say shoot.
That is true, but...
I needed her to shoot the red stomach.
I did forget about that though, thank you for the reminder.
But she would shoot the mouth and I needed her to...
Well, I needed her to shoot the mouth and then the stomach.
And she just wouldn't...
She wouldn't register the stomach.
She sells.
Yes.
Okay, please.
Okay.
Wait, oh no, I don't have it up yet.
Ted threw Fred three free throws.
I don't have it yet.
I don't have it.
Okay, I got it, I got it.
Okay.
Fuzzy wuzzy.
Nope.
I hate this one.
A big black bug bit a big blue bug and the big blue bug bled black blood.
Yeah.
A peck of pickled peppers.
A peck of pickled peppers Peter Piper picked.
If Peter Piper picked a peck of pickled peppers, how many peppers did Peter Piper pick?
I got it.
Peter Piper picked a peck of pickled peppers.
A peck of pickled peppers Peter Piper picked.
If Peter Piper picked a peck of pickled peppers, how many peppers did Peter Piper pick?
Yeah.
Thank you.
Alright, heal.
We're sorry, I'm gonna have to do tongue twisters a couple times.
She sells.
A couple times.
Yes.
Guys, this is how you heal, isn't it so fun?
Okay.
Pick up six pick up sticks quickly.
Yeah.
Fuzzy wuzzy had no hair.
Fuzzy wuzzy wasn't fuzzy wuzzy.
Yeah.
Fuzzy wuzzy was a bear.
Fuzzy wuzzy had no hair.
Fuzzy wuzzy wasn't fuzzy wuzzy.
Yeah.
A peck of pickled peppers.
A peck of pickled peppers Peter Piper picked.
If Peter Piper picked a peck of pickled peppers, how many peppers did Peter Piper pick?
I got it.
Peter Piper picked a peck of pickled peppers.
A peck of pickled peppers Peter Piper picked.
If Peter Piper picked a peck of pickled peppers, how many peppers did Peter Piper pick?
Yeah!
Okay, two more.
She sells.
And then we'll save.
Yes.
Crazy good.
What?
Is that a new one?
The boot black brought the boot back.
What does that mean?
I don't think we've done that one before.
No!
Blood.
I need to chuck.
That one's really good, I think, for practicing.
Chuck chuck if a woodchuck could chuck wood.
A woodchuck would chuck as much as wood a woodchuck could chuck could.
How much wood would a woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck could chuck wood?
A woodchuck would chuck as much as it could chuck if a woodchuck could.
You're welcome!
Still picking on Peter.
How were the peppers already pickled when Peter picked them?
Peter Piper picked a peck of pickled peppers.
A peck of pickled... What is a peck?
Like a branch?
How are...
How are cucumbers grown?
He picked them from the store.
A peck is a volume.
It's a unit of measure?
It's a bunch?
It's like a pinch of something?
Oh, the unit of measurement.
Save point.
I think we're okay.
Run.
So that was section two, I think.
Oh gosh, thank goodness there's no Irish wristwatch for this one.
We'll use our final save part.
Our final save slot.
Irish wristwatch.
Irish wristwatch!
See, I can do it.
Alright, section one.
Yeah, that was section two.
So we need section one and section three.
Oh, there's a heal!
Let's go.
Nice.
Uh oh, but what about...
What about...
Oh no, how do we get to section...
To the right?
Or like in that area?
Section four.
Hospitals in this world must be amazing.
True, I hope not though.
I hope we just find the item.
No!
Lampy, thanks for the good...
Fleet.
Hind legs.
Front legs.
Nope.
Front leg.
Left stomach.
Nope.
Enemy two.
Mouth.
Stomach.
Oh, reload.
Mouth.
Stomach.
Oh my god, wait.
No, no.
Enemy one.
Fleet.
Oh, that was so close.
Enemy two.
Stomach.
Please, it's so close.
Fleet.
It's so close.
Stomach.
Ok, there we go.
Left stomach.
Mouth.
No.
I can't!
Run.
The bedroom.
Shoot!
Left stomach.
Red stomach.
Mouth.
Flee!
Flee, flee, flee, flee, flee.
There we go, there we go.
Mouth.
Red stomach.
Oh my god!
That was like so clean!
That was so clean you guys!
Oh my gosh!
Yeah!
That was so good.
I don't think we got hurt once.
I don't know how it registers mouth as stomach.
I don't know, I don't know.
Okay, I'm gonna risk it.
Save point.
Run.
So I'm going to try for the VIP area and see if there is another grenade launcher in there.
And also what else is in there.
Because I want to explore.
Risk it for the biscuit, for the biscuit.
Risk it for the biscuit, I want a biscuit.
That's the one we just did, right?
Very good.
Crazy how a fight like that is clean, but compared to the rest of the game it was.
Not a comment on Mint's abilities, but the game is...
I know, right?
VIP seating 4.
Run.
Okay, so we'll go do this.
And that's why I saved, because if we softlock ourself, we'll just die somehow and reload.
I can't go any farther if this thing is here.
What should I do?
Launcher.
Okay, leave it up to me.
I hardly know her.
Wow, blasted!
I got blasted.
Holy loud.
Let's go.
Run.
Yes.
Or she can't run upstairs.
That's a safety hazard.
You clapped on the monster when it splosh splosh.
Heal capsule!
That's good.
What else is there?
Oh no.
Section 3.
Wait, which section was it?
Section 1.
Run.
Which section was it?
I can't remember.
This one?
No.
Section 2.
Are we softlocked?
Section 3.
No, section 4.
Run.
Okay, heal jelly is important though.
No, wait.
Yeah.
There it is.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Right eye.
Shoot.
Left eye.
Middle eye.
Red eye.
Flee.
Why did you run right into it?
Mouth.
Oh my god, tail.
Okay.
Hind leg.
Front leg.
Actually that works.
Mouth.
Flee.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Okay.
Left stomach.
Where are you going?
Flee.
Why flee?
Why do you run right into it, you stupid ass.
Left stomach.
Flee.
She jumped and dodged it.
Amazing.
Right stomach.
Left stomach.
Reload.
Red stomach.
Oh my god, we got it.
Mouth.
Red stomach.
It's tough going.
Yeah it is.
Oh my god.
We got it.
And now we do tongue twisters.
We do tongue twisters.
We save.
We go.
How many do we have?
Two?
We're in.
And we got four heal capsules.
She sells.
Yeah!
We are so good right now.
Yes.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Ted threw Fred three free throws.
Awesome.
Fuzzy wuzzy had no hair.
Fuzzy wuzzy wasn't fuzzy wuzzy.
Fuzzy wuzzy was a bear.
Fuzzy wuzzy had no hair.
Fuzzy wuzzy wasn't fuzzy wuzzy.
Yeah, I'm very good at that one.
A woodchuck could chuck wood.
A woodchuck would chuck as much as it could if a woodchuck could.
Okay, your turn.
Good.
Why doesn't the second part have the same cadence as the first one?
It drives me insane.
Okay.
We'll do one more.
She sells.
I am becoming a professional, yeah.
Yes.
Like it should be like a woodchuck could woodchuck chuck.
I don't know.
Ted threw Fred three free throws.
Awesome.
Maybe it's intentional.
On the seashore.
She sells seashells on the seashore.
She is sure.
She sells.
She sells our seashells.
She is sure.
I knew it.
I feel you should suggest this to Henya and Leah.
Oh my god, you're right.
She sells.
I flubbed it up in the second part.
I knew I did too.
Yes.
What?
No, no, no.
I said yes.
She...
She sells.
She sounded so sad.
Yes.
Gosh, okay.
Another time.
Okay.
Pick up six pickup sticks quickly.
That one is just trying to make me say a naughty word.
Fuzzy wuzzy.
No.
Sheep shouldn't sleep in a shack.
Sheep should sleep in a shed.
Okay.
Last one.
No.
Okay, I'm gonna try and do it fast.
Ah, never ever.
It does not register that one at all.
She sells.
That's the guy she...
I did do it perfect.
It hates me with that one.
Yes.
Ted threw Fred three free throws.
Okay.
Inexplicably mimicking him hiccuping and amicably welcoming him in.
I don't think...
I don't think I've ever had to try that one.
Okay, that's good enough.
Save point.
That's a rare one.
Run.
What is it?
Save point.
Run.
Okay.
Oh, we made it through the restaurant everybody.
Tongue twister god.
Blood, blood.
Blood, blood, blood, bug blood.
Nice.
Nice, and we got to...
We got the extra health pack even.
My hair, what about it?
What about my hair?
Wait, do you want me to have short hair?
Okay.
Which section was it?
Section 3.
Red.
Was it section 3 or 4?
Nope.
Section 4.
No!
Right eye.
Flee.
I think I'm just going to die you guys.
I don't want to do this.
Flee.
Enemy 2.
Hind leg.
Front leg.
Left stomach.
Right stomach.
Red stomach.
Oh my god!
Right.
Move right.
That was so clean.
Reload.
It heard that I was going to kill myself.
The game knew I was going to kill myself.
Yeah!
Move right.
Right.
Right eye.
Move right.
Left eye.
Middle eye.
Red eye.
Body.
Reload.
Move right.
Body.
Tail.
Wait, did we get something extra for that?
Oh my god!
He gave us another one!
We could farm them here.
Interesting.
Okay, so we are at...
Section 3.
Is it section?
Guys, it's so...
The thing is all backwards.
I can't tell which is what.
I know, we killed him so clean.
Yes, sir.
I thought about ending myself.
It's 4?
Section 4.
Run.
Thank you.
Thank you for the help.
Wait, no.
No.
No!
Left stomach.
Oh wait.
Hind leg.
Left stomach.
Right stomach.
Oh no.
Flee.
Oh my god.
Right stomach.
No.
Red stomach.
Flee.
Mouth.
Red stomach.
Flee.
Red.
Red stomach.
Okay, nice, nice.
Mouth.
Shoot.
Flee.
Mouth.
Shoot.
Stomach.
Wait, do we get another one then?
Do we get another another?
She is an awful shot.
She truly is.
She is just a waitress.
She is just...
Wait.
Panel.
Hello?
Go to panel.
Check panel.
Oh my god, a chandelier.
Chandelier.
Launcher.
It's okay, we got some extras which is kind of neat.
We farmed a couple.
There's more.
Chandelier.
Yeah, we did get a couple.
Launcher.
Yeah, we still have two.
Okay, what's in there?
Wait, maybe I should have saved.
Oh well.
That's fine.
Oh, there's a person!
Hello, mister?
Are you hurt from the grenade launcher?
Oh my god, he's a chef.
Ansem the Wise?
Where did they go?
Did they get eaten?
Oh damn!
Am I real?
This is a restaurant actually.
You're welcome.
And me too.
What are you giving me?
Wait, is this for the elevator?
Oh nice!
Let's go.
I don't know.
That's such a bizarre...
He didn't even mention his family.
That's how you say it in Spanish.
Nice.
I hope you'll be able to see your family again.
I have no family.
It's exit...yeah.
Exit 1.
Actually wait.
Save point.
Run.
The elevator.
Yeah, I know.
The elevator!
Yeah!
Nice.
Would you guys play a game like this?
Made in modern times.
I watched...what was it?
What's his name?
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, that's what I'm talking about!
What's his name?
Oh my gosh.
He...I saw him play a game of...
With...it was like an AI using...
Like it used basically chat GPT.
But as...
With...but voiced speech.
And it really truly felt like this game.
Charlie!
Yeah, the moist critical.
Exit 1.
I think...I think we'll probably get ambushed in the next...
Oh, we're here.
Or this is just a transition cutscene.
Okay, we probably will get ambushed out here I imagine.
Since we did before.
Elevator.
Don't get ambushed.
We made it!
Okay.
What is it?
0-4-2-3 0-4-2-3 No, no, where are you going?
No!
Elevator.
I answered it!
Oh there.
Touch panel.
0-4-2-3 You can use code Boomer to get...
I tried that.
Strawberry Q.
Yeah, because they sent that to me for free.
It's okay.
Safety.
Please do not release the safety bar.
Hey, look!
There's section 3.
Which was sealed during the tremor.
That looks messed up.
There...wouldn't be anyone left.
The lights will now be turned off for optimum visibility of the external environment.
Please enjoy the cosmic vista.
The cosmic vista.
Sightseeing in space.
Emotional music.
They say that people finally began viewing themselves objectively after they started seeing Earth from space.
Perhaps also...
Maybe they felt a separation with reality as well.
But what about you?
What about me?
Are you really alive?
Am I alive?
No.
You are such a joker operator.
I'm a ghost!
What were the first words your mother taught you as a child?
Pee-pee.
Words of greeting are always good.
We seem to have reached the junction.
This is how you greet people in French everybody.
Pee-pee.
Was what?
It's German for we.
We.
Also French.
Oh, just kidding.
We.
Oui, oui.
Pee-pee.
Mom pointed at herself and then at me and taught me that word.
I love the word.
Oui.
It makes it seem as if I'm not all alone.
Just like now.
How does she know where the camera is?
She loves the word oui, oui.
Hey, what's your favorite word or saying?
My favorite word...
Mint.
You don't have one?
Okay.
You're probably thinking, why is she asking me this all of a sudden?
Hot dog.
I should have said that last time.
Well, I just wanted to get to know you better.
Hot dog.
After all, we don't know anything about each other.
Despite the fact that we're partners, right?
You don't tell me anything.
Would you like to know more about me?
Oh my gosh, yes.
Yes, please.
You haven't told me anything.
You might not believe me, but...
Also, these...
I've never had a boyfriend before.
Why are you telling me that?
I'm a girl without a heart.
Oh my gosh, and I'm a ghost without a heart.
But I'm beginning to understand.
It's better for people to be with someone rather than being alone.
Thank you, thank you.
When we get back to Earth...
Rio, the home record.
Maybe I'll get you to introduce me to someone.
I was going to say...
Please remain seated until the safety bar has been lifted.
Well then again, what about you?
What?
But I suppose there is no chance of that, huh?
She wants me!
The views during that whole segment were so beautiful, so good.
Oh my gosh.
Suggesting the scimitar.
Doki michi kuro.
No, no, no.
Oh my gosh.
Finally, her reflexes.
What happened?
That's a death flag.
Wobble.
Johnston, what can I help you with?
Good thing we just got out of there.
We got a severe wobble.
Wobble, wobble, wobble, wobble.
Okay, where are we?
That's a great question.
Exit 2.
Run.
That's where we are going to go.
Oh, that's a bad option.
We chose the wrong way.
Right eye.
Left eye.
Flee.
Middle eye.
Red eye.
Body.
Tail.
Flee.
Body.
Oh my gosh, this is stupid.
Stop.
Flee.
Move right.
Move left.
We are going to die here because of this.
We are going to die here.
Body.
Move.
If you die, you get to answer hotdog.
That's true.
We are going to have to do this.
Okay, we are not going to go to exit 2 first.
God dang it.
That room is tough because it's so small.
Oh man.
We will go to exit 1 instead.
Ah.
Alright.
Exit 1.
Yeah, emotional scene, take 2.
Wait, what was the code?
0423, I think.
Elevator.
Yeah.
8008.
I think it was, right?
0423.
Yeah.
I remember.
Favorite word is Rio.
That would be kind of insane.
Die.
No way.
At least this is a nice little break time.
See, like this view is insane.
So awesome.
It looks so good.
Like the aesthetic and everything.
Looks so awesome.
Game does look good, yeah.
Yes.
Milk.
What are you talking about?
Ok.
Wir.
We.
I'm going to tell that.
I'm going to say Kiara.
Wir.
We.
So...
Ok guys.
Riz 100, right now.
Riz 100.
Yep.
Hey.
What's your favorite word or saying?
Rio.
Is that right?
You're probably thinking, why is she asking me this all of a sudden?
That lukewarm reaction.
Well, I just wanted to get to know you better.
Nevermind.
I take it back.
After all, we don't know anything about each other.
Despite the fact that we're partners, right?
We're partners in crime.
Would you like to know more about me?
No.
Ok.
Unless she's going to tell me anyway.
Why is that unbelievable?
Why is that unbelievable, huh?
You think you're an egotistical woman?
You think you're so sought after?
Huh?
Guys, Rio is single.
You just have to tell her every command.
Actually, you guys...
Some of you might actually really love that.
Some of you might be really excited about that actually.
Well then again, what about you?
But I suppose there's no chance of that, huh?
Some people would be like, I love a girl without free will.
She's so stupid.
I like her.
She's best that way.
No, Rio!
I have to not die here because I don't want to go through all that.
This cutscene is so long.
A severe wobble was detected in the space station's rotation.
The station was placed on emergency status.
Although the wobble will not interfere with it's orbit.
Elevator use is prohibited.
How are we supposed to get back?
I guess...
Well, she did say she wanted to go to my room.
Right?
What if Gio's on the other side?
She's like a Metal Gear character.
Who?
Which Metal Gear?
Exit 1.
Alright.
To the bed.
Okay.
Alright, if we can at least get a save point that would be great.
Meant in Rio's wedding.
You may kiss the bride.
Stomach!
This is horribly wrecked.
Ahead of here is the senior staff section.
Where should I go?
We got quite a few rooms, eh?
We got break room.
We got manager's office.
Wait, look we're in section...
It's showing us the sections that we have left.
So there's other and then laboratory.
I guess we'll go to the...
Break room.
The break room.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Get ambushed.
I don't even know what it is.
Right eye.
Left eye.
Middle eye.
Shoot!
Red eye.
Run!
Oh my god!
That was so messed up.
Tail!
Shoot!
Now!
Oh no.
Shoot!
Mouth!
You had one shot left Rio.
Come on girl.
At least she did some good aim at least.
Break room.
Run.
Square bar!
Thanks for the 10 gift!
Thank you!
Save points.
No.
Leave.
Run!
Oh my god.
Is this...
Run!
Left claw?
Recover.
Reco...
I hate this one so much.
Eye!
Flee!
Oh my god.
It's the fact that she...
Flee!
It's the fact that she doesn't...
Mouth!
Oh my god.
Flee!
Mouth!
Oh my god.
This is the worst room to do this fight in ever.
Flee!
Oh
my god.
Oh my god.
Hold on.
It's going to get in the way so much.
This is the worst room to do this fight.
And then as soon as I'm going to be able to lock on it...
It's going to disappear and move somewhere else.
I can't do this.
I think I can't do this.
Tell her to target the enemy after it disappears.
Oh my god.
Try dodging and...
Her dodge is also so bad though.
She just jumps one step.
Okay.
Alright.
Dodge!
Okay, that doesn't work.
Run!
Target the enemy!
Nevermind.
Flee!
Run!
Shoot!
Oh my god.
Dodge left!
Dodge...
Dodge right...
Back!
Okay, that works.
Almost didn't work.
Flee!
I can't get it though.
Dodge right!
Flee!
Something do anything please.
Run!
Oh my god.
It's almost dead.
Just a little bit more.
Ai!
Run!
Flee!
Ai!
Oh, nevermind.
Flee!
Oh my god.
Ai!
No!
Flee!
At least she did it.
Okay, okay.
Oh my gosh.
Flee!
Actually, fine.
Whatever.
I don't care anymore.
Flee!
Ai!
Maybe I should jump there.
Jump!
Oh my god.
It worked though.
Jump!
Ai!
Shoot!
Okay, you know what?
Whatever.
Jump!
It works!
Ai!
Oh my gosh.
I can't believe it works.
I mean we wasted like three health I think on that thing.
Holy cow.
Oh my gosh.
We had four.
We had four health.
I want you to give me instructions.
She sells.
Gilroy, thanks for three months!
Oh.
Yes.
Okay.
Ted threw Fred three free throws.
No!
I did blow that one.
Holy, that fight was so frustrating.
I need like a break after that.
She sells.
I need such a break.
Holy cow.
Yes!
If you can handle this, you can handle Dark Souls.
Around the rugged rocks, the ragged rascal ran.
I think if I can handle this game, I can do anything in my afterlife.
Truly.
I think if I can do this game, I can do anything.
Fuzzy wuzzy was a bear.
Fuzzy wuzzy had no hair.
Fuzzy wuzzy wasn't fuzzy wuzzy.
Finish Iwariya.
Oh gosh, this one again?
She stood on the balcony, inexplicably mimicking him, hiccuping, and amicably welcoming him in.
Let's not get too far.
I did it!
Beat Celeste.
We'll go to full health.
She sells.
I will save, don't worry.
I'm getting my health full and then I'm going to save.
Despite everything, there isn't an easier way to kill this enemy.
Around the rugged rocks, the ragged rascal ran.
I'm a powerful gamer.
Thank you.
Fuzzy wuzzy was a bear.
Fuzzy wuzzy had no hair.
Fuzzy wuzzy wasn't fuzzy wuzzy.
Fuzzy wuzzy was a bear.
Fuzzy wuzzy had no hair.
Fuzzy wuzzy wasn't fuzzy wuzzy.
The jump strike, as soon as we started doing that, was so good actually.
Should have done that earlier.
But we learned.
We learned.
Again?
She stood on the balcony, inexplicably mimicking him, hiccuping, and amicably welcoming him in.
Nice.
The amount of time she got caught in the heel of that blast.
Right, that's what I'm saying.
I should have just been jumping to avoid it instead of trying to flee when she wasn't even targeting it.
So she didn't know how far to run.
It's okay.
We've only fought that enemy like what, two...
Times?
Now?
So...
We've learned.
Save point.
Yeah, so we learned.
You say flee and she goes three steps.
The reason that is happening is because she...
I learned this last stream.
When she flees, she is running from whatever enemy she is targeting.
So if she's not targeting anything, she just runs a couple steps.
It's not that she... It's not that she...
It's so stupid.
Yeah, she can't register what she's fleeing from.
Exactly, exactly.
So it's like... It's so frustrating.
It's so frustrating.
Anyway, we're good.
We're calm, we're cool.
We got through it.
Gamer, yoohoo!
Welcome to membership and Celestia!
Welcome to membership too!
Thank you guys!
TV.
No.
No, no, no, no!
I said TV.
Cancel save, yes.
I said it though.
I said it.
I said TV.
TV.
OK.
Are you kidding me right now?
Head.
Stomach.
Oh my gosh.
Flee.
Enemy 2.
Move left.
Mouth.
Shoot.
Stomach.
Mouth.
Shoot.
Shoot?
Am I hitting it?
Shoot.
Strafe.
Am I... She's hitting the chair.
Oh.
Mouth.
Shoot.
Flee.
Enemy 1.
Stop.
Shoot.
Stomach.
Mouth.
What is... Oh my gosh, it's this guy.
Enemy 2.
Enemy 3.
I don't know.
What is that?
What is that one?
Enemy 3.
Oh, enemy 1.
Okay, I see it.
Enemy 1.
Right eye.
Left eye.
Middle eye.
Red eye.
Okay.
Head.
Oh, nice.
Mouth.
Stomach.
Or that.
Whatever you choose to do.
What should I do?
Move left.
Stomach.
Shoot.
Reload.
Yes, shall we?
Shall we move on?
Yes, we shall.
Let's move on.
TV.
Oh my god, another grenade.
This is a lot.
How do you think I feel?
I've been playing this game for 8 hours it says.
8 hours of this.
Of...
Of this.
Save point.
I don't even know how much more we have left to go.
I don't even know.
Let's check.
I'm gonna check the guide and see how much longer the guide is.
Let's see.
I don't even know.
Wait, observatory restaurant.
Break room.
That's where we are at.
1, 2, 3, 5, 6.
We are almost there you guys, actually.
We are actually not doing so bad, I think.
Sorry, my voice is a little icky today.
We are actually not doing so bad.
Almost halfway.
I don't know how long this game is.
Can you imagine?
Imagine if the rest was really...
There's not a lot of areas but it was just that long.
Vending machine.
Right.
I'm glad I did this though.
It's still kind of fun.
Top of vending machine.
Yes.
Look up.
Gamers don't look up.
Check top of vending machine.
Check above vending machine.
It's definitely in the...
No.
Stop.
Ok, hold on.
Table.
The table.
Ok.
When something frustrates you, just go to another place.
ZNRO, thanks for the superchat.
Wow, there's a lot of stuff here.
Three Japanese tongue twisters.
Namamugi, namagome, namatamago.
I know that one.
I know that one, actually.
Namamugi, namagome, namatamago.
Uri futatsu, nasu futatsu.
Basugasu bakahatsu.
If you beat the game, you unlock new game plus with a new sexy outfit for the first half of the game.
And another new sexy out...
Are you being...
Are you being real?
Washi washi, welcome to Manbushu.
I don't know it though.
I actually don't know it.
Nyanyanyanyanyanyanyanyanyanyanyanyanyanyanyanyanyanyanyan...
Remember when you were going to take days off for your voice when you didn't?
Remember when you weren't such a bitch, Murphy?
Shut up!
What are we looking at?
Oh no!
The the the the the...
Coffee.
The little... the things disappeared.
Oh, coffee powder.
Check coffee powder.
Ride in it?
I don't know, look under it.
It's shiny.
Clean coffee powder.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yes, do it, do it.
Do it, do it, do it.
What is that?
Let's go!
For the bird.
Yippee!
Um, read note.
Yes.
Read report.
Usurped?
Okay.
Is that the scientist?
That's the scientist guy, right?
Uh, check left cup.
No.
Middle cup.
I didn't say blue cup.
Uh...
Center cup.
Oh!
Why'd you do that?
What?
Why did you do that?
Right cup.
Right mug.
Uh...
Left mug.
Oh, she got it.
Oh!
We got another chip!
I don't know what these do, but we're getting chips.
I don't think there's really anything else to check, but um...
Box.
No!
Why did she shoot the chair?
Table.
Why did she shoot it?
Just to show how good the infrastructure is.
All the furniture here is indestructible.
Um...
Cardboard.
What?!
Table.
The table.
Coffee.
No, ma'am.
Uh...
Box.
Oh!
Okay, I give up.
I don't care about the coffee.
I don't care.
Um...
Vending machine.
Yes.
I don't know!
Okay, um...
Dispenser.
Which dispenser are you talking about?
Check right dispenser.
Oh?
Is something in there?
There was nothing.
Okay.
I'm disappointed.
Me too, actually.
Top of left vending machine.
Oh my gosh, that worked!
Miss legendary coffee scene?
Okay, fine.
I'll go back.
I'll tell her to drink the coffee.
Check left dispenser.
Yeah.
It would be good.
I'm looking cute today!
You can thank my mama.
Uh...
I don't know how else to say box, you guys.
I don't know how to say box without her thinking that I'm gonna...
That she wants to walk.
I can't even say cardboard.
Cardboard box.
Oh my god.
Trash can.
No, it's not!
Look inside trash can.
Check trash can.
No!
Open trash can.
Hmm...
Left dispenser of right vending machine.
No, you checked the right one.
Right dispenser of right vending machine.
Middle right?
Middle right!
No!
Vending machine.
I love Antarctica!
Don't melt!
What should I say for the trash can?
Middle right dispenser.
Middle left dispenser.
Oh, check third.
Check third dispenser.
The third.
Oh, search.
Search trash can.
Tactician zero!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Examine trash can.
I think she has to open it maybe.
I don't know how though.
Throw Rio in trash can.
Rio!
Inspect trash can.
What?
I tried look inside.
Look inside trash can.
That wouldn't work.
I think I almost just...
If I had blood vessels, I would have burst one.
Surely, just then.
Welcome back!
Thank you!
Open trash can.
Knock over trash can.
Open lid.
Open trash can lid.
Yes!
Oh my god!
I didn't even need it.
I didn't need it.
I wish I would say like dispenser one, dispenser two, dispenser three, you know?
Check dispenser three.
I give up.
I think it's just a cup, you guys.
So I think there's not really a point.
I watched bits of all three streams and it feels like the exact same bits are repeating over and over.
Yeah.
Save point.
We'll do this before we check the galley just in case we get ambushed again.
Minto purgatory.
Something something insanity is doing the same thing over and over again and expecting different results.
Is that not the definition?
Something something.
Gosh.
You know what they should do?
They should give...
They should...
To torture people, they should...
Like, you know...
Say if...
If...
If I were to be torturing someone, I think I would give them this game and a crunchy mic.
I would give them this game and a crunchy mic and say...
Beat it in under ten hours.
If anyone says Minto is not smart, show them real.
Who says that?
Galley.
The galley.
Okay.
I knew it!
Right eye.
Right.
Dodge right.
Middle eye.
Right eye.
Left eye.
Red eye.
Mouth.
Body.
We got him as he was...
Run!
That was so close.
Dodge left.
Right eye.
Middle eye.
Left eye.
Red eye.
Mouth.
Dodge left.
Body.
Tail.
Oh no, she got reload.
She didn't reload.
Why didn't you reload?
You said you were going to.
Tail.
Is there another one?
Oh my gosh.
Right eye.
Run!
Run.
Left eye.
Shoot.
Middle eye.
Red eye.
Mouth.
Tail.
Dodge right.
Is that it?
I don't think you can actually use grenades in the battles.
I think they are literally only for anything.
I don't know.
I have no idea.
Galley.
There better be something good in here.
Oh there is a health pack.
Coffee.
No!
Stop, stop, stop.
Stop.
Galley.
How many do I have?
I have a few of them actually.
I have four launcher grenades.
Chips.
Tissue.
Yes.
Tissue paper.
Check tissue paper.
Wow.
Okay.
Cups.
Potato chips.
Sure.
Check behind T.
Eat tissue paper.
Yes.
She is not hungry you guys.
Eat.
Snack.
What is...
Yellow box.
Yes.
What is that?
Check T bag.
Why did she just tilt her head?
Search T bag.
T bag.
Oh my god.
It's a ticket.
What's this one?
Jump back!
That's actually pretty good.
Red bag.
Yeah, what is that?
Sugar.
Oh, I thought it was potato chip.
Eat sugar.
She's so mean.
Brown box.
What did I just say?
I don't know.
Oh god.
Table.
Oh wait, sorry.
I meant not the table.
You know what?
It's fine.
Drink coffee.
Cardboard box.
Okay.
Coffee bags.
The vocabulary in this game is so bizarre sometimes.
Why is it coffee bag?
Why is it not just coffee?
Okay, galley.
We'll get the health behind the coffee bag.
And then we shall save and then we shall leave.
Coffee bag.
I said coffee earlier.
It did not work.
Instead you must say coffee bag.
I don't know why you can't just say coffee.
Save point.
The game is such an enigma.
It's the vocabulary.
Yeah, it gets me so bad sometimes.
Alright, we save and we go.
We're going to the manager room.
I don't know where that is but we're gonna go.
Wait, what was my health like?
I actually didn't see.
Let's see.
There are bags inside but it is still confusing.
I must become the mind of Rio to understand anything.
She only understands very specific things.
Okay.
How many...
Oh, we got three health!
That's not bad.
And our health, it could be better but if we die it's okay.
Androgoz!
Thanks for the 20 gifted!
Hallway.
Thank you for the 20 gifted Androgoz!
I really appreciate it.
Wait, what's happening?
Oh my gosh!
Gino!
Oh my god!
Why?
Why is he so rough with her?
Revolver Ocelot!
I don't think we need to introduce her.
Shoot!
Kick in the balls!
Kick balls!
Punch!
Kiss!
Low kick!
Oh my god!
I think we just game over.
No!
Rio you are CQC!
Oh my god!
He is so scary!
Oh thank god we just saved.
What the hell?
The
balls, what else is there?
What else could there be?
Okay, and he can't shoot him.
Red stomach.
Okay, hallway.
Here we go.
Run?
I don't think we can.
He got us grabbed.
I'll try though.
I'll try running.
Use your womanly charm.
Number two in his mouth.
No, my first order was shoot.
Why are you dressed like that?
Sexy pose, Adriel.
He's scaring me.
He scares me.
Mao Mao, thanks for the five gifts.
Sexy pose.
Run.
Spit.
Push him.
Ask about stone.
I don't know.
Spin gun.
What?
She's like I need you to tell me what to do.
I give you answers and you don't listen to any of them woman.
What do you want me to do?
This is like asking a girl what she wants for dinner.
You want Wendy's?
I can't.
I'm not in the mood for burgers.
Taco Bell.
No, I don't want tacos.
Threaten him.
Okay, we'll threaten him.
Hallway.
Leave the room?
Okay.
Rio, shoot.
I can't do it.
It's no good.
The guide says threaten.
Okay, thank you.
So you guys were serious when it said threaten.
I'm gonna need some more water in a bit.
Rio, what's going on?
Why are you dressed like that?
Gina, there's something I want you to see.
No, I can't do it.
It's no good.
Can't do it.
So reference is a metal gear reference everybody.
I'm sorry.
Listen to me Rio.
Ask him about ligmar.
Threaten him.
Okay, I'll try that.
Drop your weapon.
Thanks for 10 months.
Rio...
Why did you sound like that?
You did sound more annoyed.
You sounded whiny baby.
I feel like if you said shoot, it should register as...
Oh yeah, I'll pretend... I'll act like I'm gonna shoot him.
You know?
What's that blue ball?
Spit it out.
Rio, you're not a...
The exhibit room is right down the hall.
What?
Oh damn.
Only the manager carries a key to the exhibit room.
Mr. Tanaka is under guard by the rescue team in the receiving board.
Okay, I'll spit it out.
Thank you.
December, do you remember?
Your information's old.
Okay, let's go operator.
I'm gonna start telling that to you guys when you tell me something that I should do in a game, but I've already tried it.
Your information's old.
That's crazy.
I guess, manager's office.
The backseating outdates.
Run.
Can we take his gun?
Do we need it?
I feel like ours is better.
No?
She's running.
She's a running girl.
Running Rio.
And we get ambushed.
Flee.
Oh my gosh, this is the second one.
Enemy 2.
Flee.
Oh no, we're stuck in a small little area.
Enemy 1.
In her mouth.
What?
There's more?
Tongue.
Body.
Flee.
Enemy 2.
Body.
Front limb.
Hind limb.
Shoot.
Body.
That works too.
No.
Tongue.
Hind limb.
I don't think she can reach it.
In her mouth.
No.
In her...
In her mouth.
Recover.
Nice.
Enemy 1.
Front limb.
You didn't reload yet girl!
Reload.
Jump back.
Run.
Oh my gosh.
Enemy 2.
Hind limb.
Nice.
Enemy 3.
Mouth.
Head.
Stomach.
Jump.
Stop.
Run!
God dammit Brio.
What the fuck?
Mouth.
Stomach.
Body.
In her mouth.
Front limb.
Body.
Tongue.
Ok that works.
Enemy 3.
Stomach.
Mouth.
Oh my god.
Shoot.
Recover.
She needs to...
Stomach.
Shoot.
Reload.
Dodge left.
Shoot.
Nice.
Ok.
Oh my gosh.
Body.
Nope.
How can I bait it over here?
I need to run behind it so we can get the hind limb.
Tongue.
Eye.
Oh nevermind.
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Auto fire?
I feel like she misses more with auto fire.
That's why I don't use it much.
Manager's office.
Run.
We only have one heal capsule left.
It's ok.
Our health is good at least.
Right now.
For now.
Oh I should save huh?
Oh my gosh.
Too late.
Jump back!
Oh my gosh.
We are so dead.
Nope.
Sorry.
Hold on.
Wait.
What the heck is that thing?
Oh this is the stomach creature.
Ok, ok, ok.
We are so dead.
Front leg.
Hind leg.
Are you kidding me right now?
Enemy 2.
Hind leg.
Front leg.
Enemy 1.
Right stomach.
Left stomach.
Flea.
Right stomach.
Left stomach.
Enemy 3.
Hind leg.
Front leg.
Left stomach.
Right stomach.
Flea.
Enemy 1.
Ah run!
Flea.
Enemy 3.
Left stomach.
Red stomach.
Mouth.
Flea.
Enemy 1.
Blah!
Run!
Flea!
Mouth!
Red stomach!
Flee!
Turn around!
Turn around...
Flee!
Left stomach!
Enemy 2!
Right stomach!
Left stomach!
Enemy 1!
Right stomach!
Flee!
Reload!
Enemy 2!
Left stomach!
Red stomach!
Mouth!
Oh my god!
Left stomach!
Mouth!
Stomach!
Watch closely and guide me!
Mouth!
Stomach!
Reload!
Watch closely and guide me!
Stomach!
Left stomach!
Mouth!
Watch closely and guide me!
Left stomach!
Mouth!
Watch closely and back!
Left stomach!
Left Stomach.
Left Stom Mouth.
Red stomach.
Mouth.
Bleed.
Red stomach.
Tail.
It won't let me in.
Red stomach.
Tail.
You shut the mouth too many times, Rio!
Bleed.
Red stomach.
Run.
Bleed.
Oh my god.
Tail.
Red stomach.
Body.
Oh my gosh.
Flee.
Body.
I can't do anything.
Flee.
Wait.
Body.
Because I used to be able to get it in the mouth and that would flip it upside down, but she won't shoot it in the mouth anymore.
I don't want to heal.
I only have one left.
I think I might have to though.
I think I might have to.
Recover.
Mouth.
Flee.
Oh, tail.
Yes.
Tail.
Red stomach.
Flee.
I need you to run to the other side, Rio.
Red stomach.
Flee.
Oh my god.
We lost almost all the health.
Red stomach.
Shoot.
Auto fire.
Strafe.
Red stomach.
Flee.
Shoot.
Auto fire.
Red stomach.
Flee.
Shoot.
I don't know what to do.
I don't...
Tail.
I don't know what to do.
Run.
Flee.
I don't know what to do.
Red stomach.
Mouth.
Jump back.
Flee.
Red stomach.
Tail.
Shoot.
Run.
Tail.
Shoot.
Red stomach.
Run.
Hallway.
Leave the room?
Okay.
When we get to the cutscene, I'm gonna go to get some more water since my throat hurts.
Oh!
Rio!
Gino!
What the hell are you doing here?
Wait!
Rio, what's going on?
Why are you dressed like that?
Gino, there's something I want you to see.
You're babbling.
Give me that weapon.
You should wait at the receiving port with the others.
Wait, listen!
I need you to watch this thing.
Listen to me, Rio.
You know I care about you.
Leave the dangerous stuff to me.
Take an escape shuttle out of here.
Hey, what should I do?
Why are you still- Okay, I'll try that.
Rio!
Put that in the drive and play it.
Get ready to stop.
There.
I need to know where this room is.
Here?
That's the, um...
Somewhere in the testing ward?
No, it's the, um...
exhibit room.
Rio, you're not a- The exhibit room is closed.
There are gems and precious metals stored there.
So you're a thief?
This is some scam by you and that operator?
I suppose you're right.
In some ways, I guess I am a thief.
Please, Gino.
Turn around.
Rio, give up this crazy idea.
You can't do it anyways.
Only the manager carries a key to the exhibit room.
Mr. Tanaka is under guard by the rescue team in the receiving port.
Oh!
Your information's old.
Okay, let's go, operator.
Where should I go?
I am back.
We will do this next fight.
Then we shall save.
Operator, what should I do?
Oh...
Then we'll do the one by the manager's office.
Manager's office.
Now, at last, the one by the manager's office is annoying, but we shall persevere.
Oh, TV, table, tray, thanks for the cat.
When is it gonna happen?
We're almost there.
Oh, it happens right here.
That's right.
Okay.
Ambush!
Flee!
Oh, that's right, there's two of them.
Enemy two.
Front limb.
Body.
Oh, actually, it's pretty good.
Hind limb.
Inner mouth.
Nice.
Dodge right.
Oh, that worked.
Oh my gosh.
Eye.
Body.
Dodge right.
Enemy one.
Front limb.
Nice.
Hind limb.
Flee.
Couldn't remember the word for that.
Hind limb.
Ah, shit.
Flee.
No, no, no.
Flee, flee, flee.
Flee.
Inner mouth.
Tongue.
Flee.
Oh my gosh.
Run fast.
Hind limb.
Flee.
Nice.
Recover.
Nope.
Why won't it hit sometimes?
Because she's bad at aiming.
Recover.
Okay.
Head.
Mouth.
Shoot.
Strafe.
I don't think she hit a single one.
Stomach.
Shoot.
That one...
wasn't so bad.
We got through that.
Actually, I'm surprised I killed the first one so easily.
Break room.
Run.
Monotone the key.
Guys, please don't backstreet me on how to say things, please.
Please don't.
Please.
I try so many different ways.
My patience is already so thin.
Save point.
Let's do this one instead.
I still don't remember why I made a separate thing, but...
Alright.
Oh my gosh, I just realized he's still laying there.
What's his name?
Gio.
Kill Gio.
Can we?
Oh my god.
Yamcha.
He's right there.
Oh, Gino.
Oops, I was getting his name wrong.
Hallway.
Okay.
Okay, bye.
Alright.
The next fight.
Manager's office.
Yes.
Run.
Oh, she actually was running.
I didn't even need to tell her.
She was like, excuse me, I am running.
How dare you.
How dare you try to save.
Oh, the other save was for seducing the monster lady.
Am I stupid?
Flee.
Enemy 2.
Right stomach.
Left stomach.
Oh wait, front leg.
Enemy 3.
Front leg.
Hind leg.
Right stomach.
Left stomach.
Body.
Red stomach.
Mouth.
Flee.
Red stomach.
Mouth.
Oh, okay.
Flee.
Red stomach.
Mouth.
Flee.
Enemy 1.
Don't run into them.
Why did she do that?
Enemy 3.
Mouth.
Red stomach.
Red mouth.
Enemy 1.
Flee.
Enemy 3.
Mouth.
Red stomach.
Enemy 2.
Enemy two.
I wonder what she's hearing.
I wonder what... I wonder what she hears instead.
Turn around!
Flee!
Hind leg!
Front leg!
Shoot!
Right stomach!
Left stomach!
Red stomach!
Flee!
Mouth!
Red stomach!
That was unlucky.
Mouth!
Red stomach!
That was so unlucky.
Flee!
Mouth!
Red stomach!
Hind leg!
Front leg!
Nice.
Red stomach!
Left stomach!
Flee!
Okay, actually, this is fine.
Shoot!
Nope.
Left stomach!
If she... If she makes it so that I can't shoot the mouth anymore, I might lose my mind.
If she makes it so I can't shoot the left stomach anymore...
Left stomach!
Flee!
Flee.
How many heal?
Oh my god.
Left stomach!
Heal!
Actually, that works.
Recover!
Left stomach!
We can go...
Left stomach.
Mouth.
Shoot.
Red stomach.
Mouth.
Oh no, it's gone.
Tail.
Flee.
Red stomach.
She's so ugly.
You are so ugly, Rio.
You are so fucking ugly.
Flee.
Tail.
Red stomach.
You know what, Rio?
Pretty girls listen.
Ugly girls don't listen.
That's why she's ugly.
Break room.
Run.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the tiny gift.
Ma'am
needs to go back to school.
She doesn't know the difference between a stomach and a mouth.
Thank you for the tiny gift.
Thank you so much.
Save point.
They are both red.
Shut up.
Oh my gosh.
Winds have changed.
Thanks for the ten gifted.
Thank you guys for all the gifted.
I think I only have one heal, but it is what it is.
Thank you for the 20 gifted.
We persevered.
We actually have full health basically.
How?
Koyuki, thanks for the gifted.
Hallway.
I don't think Rio is ESL.
I think she is...
She is a girl who saw a blue ball on TV and decided to go to space.
I don't think we can ever understand her.
I don't think we can...
Johnny, thank you for the ten gifted.
Oh my gosh.
46, 62, 65, 68, 75, 42, 78.
Thanks for the 20 gifted.
Sorry, I couldn't say your whole name because it was cut off.
Manager's office.
I felt like I just read off some launch codes.
Why is everybody gifting so much?
Thank you.
Cleary, thank you so much for the ten gifted.
Ren.
Yes.
She is a girl who is just like...
Hey, I'm watching TV back home in my apartment.
Blue ball.
I gotta go to space.
Thanks for the ten gifted.
She did say her first word was...
How do you pronounce it again?
She's like, my favorite word is we.
Holy moly.
Hi, thank you for the ten gifted.
Rio here, sever your legs please, sir.
What does that mean?
Oh my god.
He got evaporated.
Holy cow.
My man got obliterated to dust.
What the hell?
This place got torn the heck up.
He's running around naked.
What?
What's behind the couch?
Please, I just...
Mr. Tanaka?
I
think that's Mr. Tanaka.
I think that's...
Is this Mr. Tanaka?
Did he become the Hulk?
For someone...
Move!
Shoot!
There goes our full health.
Is this a boss fight?
Head!
Shoot!
Strafe!
Flee!
Oh my gosh.
Strafe!
Nice.
Flee!
Reload!
Wait, you need to...
Flee!
Oh, he does big damage.
We need to get behind him.
Tail!
Nice!
Head!
Uh-oh.
Flee!
Strafe!
Turn around?
Strafe?
Flee!
Oh, I'm so dead.
Dodge right.
Dodge left?
We're dancing?
Strafe?
Flee?
Oh, we're so dead.
We did dodge that one at least.
That's so evil.
They give you two fights.
Two fights.
No heal.
One of them is okay.
One really annoying fight and then a boss fight.
With one heal in the break room.
That's so evil.
That's so evil and then also they got rid of some of my health in this cutscene.
Hallway.
This might be a Souls game.
This might be a Souls-like.
This might be the hardest game ever to exist actually.
Exhibit room.
I give up.
You know what?
Let's go to another place.
Run.
Exhibit room.
This might be the most difficult game ever to ever exist.
It's the Dark Souls of voice control games.
I feel like, you know those people that play, that try and play games on DDR pads?
Even they would stray away from this game.
Even they would cower in fear.
They'd be like, Lifeline?
It sends a shiver up... wait, a chill up my spine.
They'd be like...
You couldn't tell me that.
Okay, dammit.
I was hoping that we could just avoid...
Manager's office.
Stay away from Lifeline like your lifeline depends on it.
Luckily I'm a ghost, so I'm already dead.
And if I were alive, I would wish that I were dead so I wouldn't have to play this game again.
I would wish for death if I were alive.
In fact, I wish I were alive so that I could die again.
Wow!
Thank you for the Haka-soba!
I don't know if you remember me from pre-graduating years ago since I barely could watch you before.
I also couldn't send any superchat on the time.
Even now I haven't been able to see your streams that often.
But I can now support you even if it's just...
This is way more than just a little bit.
You even donated a gift earlier.
Thank you so much!
Thanks for sticking around for so long too.
Thank you, it really means a lot.
I appreciate it so much.
Thank you!
An alien!
This is the room we might get stuck on for 5 hours.
I hope not though.
How many times are we going to see this cutscene after Zanzibar?
I warned him!
I warned him this would happen!
Yes you can!
Shoot!
Oh shoot!
Oh my god I didn't notice because she didn't say anything.
Shoot!
Oh my god!
What?
Girl what are you doing?
All
I said was sh...
Yeah, half a bar.
That's insane.
Strafe!
Flee!
Reload!
Strafe!
Why don't you get the head?
Flee!
Reload!
Head!
Strafe!
Flee!
The save point is right there mocking me.
Strafe!
Dodge left!
Flee!
She even dodged.
I guess at the wrong time.
Does dodge only work as a command?
What do you mean?
Everything is a command?
Hallway.
Okay.
I'm gonna be staring directly at the talk thing so that I can minimize as much health as we can.
Manager's office.
Run.
I almost said flee.
Wait, did the launcher shells actually work?
The guide says to say shoot twice.
Wait, what?
In the second time?
But I only did it once before.
Oh no, okay.
I think what it means is you say it twice, but she didn't understand me for some reason.
With launcher.
Okay, okay.
I will try it, I will try it.
So we'll get him, we'll get all the whatever, I'm assuming that is like armor around him or something.
She runs so funky.
She runs like Japanese JRPG, well that's redundant.
She runs like a JRPG heroine.
Truly.
Every girly pop runs like that in PS2 era JRPGs.
I just said ATM machine.
JJRPG.
I
warned him.
I warned him.
What did you warn him actually?
That he would die from alien?
Okay, here we go.
Shoot.
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, we barely lost any health that time.
Awesome, awesome, awesome.
Good, good, good, good, good.
Okay.
Strafe!
Flee!
Reload!
No!
That was...
That was our last heal.
I didn't even say anything.
You can't even be mad about it.
I can only laugh.
Oh my god, Sakana!
Sakana!
Oh my gosh, you should have a group face connect play along of this game.
You should have a group playthrough.
Actually, you can join them.
You all play it.
Everybody passes off the mic.
Why are you sending me... Stop.
Tenma already played it?
Oh shoot.
Then she's exempt.
She's exempt.
She's been through hell.
Everybody must know this hell.
You know what?
If I... I changed my mind.
I want the world to burn.
If I go through hell, everybody else must go through hell.
Okay, okay.
Strafe!
Flee!
Run!
I need his ass.
Flee!
Stop turning around.
Strafe!
No!
I need to bait him.
Flee!
It's so scary.
Tail!
Damn it.
It's so scary.
Hold on.
Sorry, I've been pausing a lot today.
It's because I'm trying to explain my thoughts.
It's so scary trying to bait things because you never know if they're not going to understand you.
If they're not going to understand you and then everything that you try to do just is totally for nothing.
I'll suffer with you?
Okay.
Suffer.
Suffer like I have suffered!
Flee!
Tail!
Reload!
Flee!
I can't get his butt!
Launcher!
Tail!
Does it do that much?
Strafe!
Launcher!
Reload!
Strafe!
Dodge left!
Damn it.
Flee!
Strafe!
Dodge right!
Dodge left!
Oh shit.
Reload!
Flee!
Strafe!
Launcher!
I think we got him.
I have one bullet left but whatever.
I don't care.
It was worth it.
Oh my god.
He died on the close.
How poetic.
A win is a win.
I don't care.
I don't care!
President Suzuki.
Missing.
Reporter Helen Johnson.
Senator Burton.
Missing.
Dr. Miller.
Research Supervisor Joe Powers.
Missing.
In other words...
They're dead.
I just realized our health.
Holy cow!
We...
The exhibit room's key should be in here somewhere.
Where should I start looking?
We lucked out.
We lucked out for real.
She sells...
First time tongue twisters.
Yeah, because someone used our last health.
Okay.
What?
Uh oh.
The boot black brought the boot back.
Wait, I don't have my list.
Oh no.
Wait, don't say anything.
No!
Oh, I got it.
Okay.
Sheep shouldn't sleep in a shack.
Sheep should sleep in a shed.
Yeah, Alan is the one...
Yeah, he's playing dead in the honeymoon suite.
Yeah, yeah.
A woodchuck could chuck wood.
A woodchuck would chuck as much as he could chuck if a woodchuck could.
Okay, your turn.
How much wood would a woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck could chuck wood?
A woodchuck would chuck as much as it could chuck if a woodchuck could.
Not bad.
And wasn't the president and his wife in that room as well earlier?
I think so.
Okay.
Yeah, so there's...
I think he just didn't know who all was missing and who all...
Yeah.
She sells.
I can't believe...
I can't believe she used her last health.
I can't believe it.
Yes.
I almost wish I could redo the fight.
I mean, I could, but I don't want to.
Rubber baby buggy bumper.
She got hungry.
Ah, so true.
Sheep shouldn't sleep in a shack.
Sheep should sleep in a shed.
Okay, your turn.
Sheep shouldn't sleep in a shack.
Sheep should sleep in a shed.
Awesome!
Oh, I thought I...
I bit my tongue on that one.
I didn't think I was going to get it.
She stood on the balcony inexplicably mimicking him hiccuping and amicably welcoming him in.
Okay, your turn.
I didn't think I would get that one.
Let's go to full health since the game is getting much tougher.
She sells.
And since we don't have any heals...
Yes.
Let's start with an easy one.
The boot black brought the boot back.
Okay, your turn.
Awesome.
As long as we don't get the Esaw.
Repeat after me.
Esaw, she saw...
Fuzzy Wuzzy was a bear.
Fuzzy Wuzzy had no hair.
Fuzzy Wuzzy wasn't Fuzzy Wuzzy.
I like this one.
Okay, your turn.
Fuzzy Wuzzy was a bear.
Fuzzy Wuzzy had no hair.
Fuzzy Wuzzy wasn't Fuzzy Wuzzy.
Nice try, but you blew it.
What?
No I didn't.
She sells.
So you want to play Tongue Twister with me?
Yes.
Let's start with an easy one.
What?
Pick up six pick up sticks quickly.
Okay, your turn.
I missed a word.
Pick up six pick up sticks quickly.
I've missed words before though.
Repeat after me.
A noise annoys an oyster.
But a noisy noise annoys an oyster more.
Okay, your turn.
A noise annoys an oyster.
But a noisy noise annoys an oyster more.
Awesome.
Good evening Mento.
Good morning.
Repeat after me.
Good morning Mento.
I saw Esaw kissing Kate.
Kate saw.
I saw Esaw.
Esaw saw that I saw Kate kissing Esaw.
Cosmically funny that it's like OMG great.
We got past the cutscene with almost...
Okay, your turn.
I saw Esaw kissing Kate.
Kate saw.
I saw Esaw.
Esaw saw that I saw Kate.
And Kate saw.
I saw Esaw.
Never.
I don't...
I have never ever gotten that one.
Ever.
Every single one.
She sells.
So you want to play Tongue Twister with me?
Immediately pops the last medkit to get the 2%.
I know.
Yes.
Let's start with an easy one.
It is cosmically funny, huh?
Pick up 6 pick up sticks quickly.
Okay, your turn.
Awesome.
Repeat after me.
Fuzzy Wuzzy was a bear.
Fuzzy Wuzzy had no hair.
Fuzzy Wuzzy wasn't fuzzy, was he?
Okay, your turn.
Fuzzy Wuzzy was a bear.
Fuzzy Wuzzy had no hair.
Fuzzy Wuzzy wasn't fuzzy, was he?
Good.
Repeat after me.
She stood on the balcony inexplicably mimicking him hiccuping and amicably welcoming him in.
Okay, your turn.
Awesome.
Okay, I think one more.
No, you did it.
Thanks.
I really needed that.
I'm gonna be a tongue twister master by this game.
She sells.
I feel like I'm...
So you wanna play tongue twister with me?
Yes.
Very good at that one.
Let's start with an easy one.
I feel like that one is almost ASMR.
Pick up 6 pick up sticks quickly.
The balcony one.
It has like a nice like...
Okay, your turn.
Clicky sound to each word.
Pick up 6 pick up sticks quickly.
Awesome.
Repeat after me.
She sells seashells on the seashore.
Seashells she sells are seashells she is sure.
Okay, your turn.
She sells seashells on the seashore.
Seashells she sells are seashells she is sure.
Awesome.
Repeat after me.
How much wood would a woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck could chuck wood?
A woodchuck would chuck as much as it could if a woodchuck could...
Wood, chuck, wood, wood, wood, wood.
Okay, your turn.
Good!
Wow, you did it!
I had to stop myself from laughing.
I really needed that.
I can't ever get to the second part of that one.
Okay, uh...
Save point.
I can't ever get it.
I can't do it.
Okay.
Let's do the second break room.
One.
Let's see.
I'm gonna see how much we have left of the game.
We're so close, aren't we?
Oh yeah, we are.
One, two, three, four...
Five more areas.
That's it.
Oh no, there's a bed in here.
Hotel registry.
So after the next room, it will be...
Yeah, we go to the next room.
Yeah, no shit.
Nyaru too!
Thank you for the break!
Thank you, thank you!
Is the registry paper?
Oh yeah!
We used up most of ours, so this is good actually.
Hey Nyaru, you should play this game too.
Uh, desk.
Murphy, thanks for the 10 gifted!
Robert, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Icky, thanks for the 2 gifted!
Spank, thanks for the 20 gifted!
Ducky, thanks for the gift!
Okay.
Screen.
Yes I do.
Monitor.
Standby mode.
Space station, overall map.
Check monitor.
Monitor.
It's showing...
Your mom.
Couple, thanks for the 5 gifted!
I can't believe that worked earlier.
I can't believe I said your mom and it registered that.
I'll never get over it.
Check papers.
Yeah, there's a lot of them.
Document.
Check document on floor.
Hmm.
Okay.
Check chair document.
But there's a document there.
Oh, I think it's the same thing.
Check desk document.
Appreciate your tenacity.
I would have given up a long time ago.
Minky's strong.
Well, that's what I do.
Check document on desk.
I'm not a quitter, usually.
I'm no quitter, usually.
446620 Take document on desk.
It has several numbers scribbled on it.
Hello!
Hello, hello.
No, we're not quitters.
We have to see this through to the end.
For real.
Why is the shower booth in the...
Bedroom.
Shower booth.
That's curious.
Curious.
Red.
Step all over his clothes.
His steaming, stinky...
Clothes on the ground.
And it's see-through.
Oh, nice.
Nice,
nice, nice.
How many do we have now of those?
Three.
Okay.
Bed.
Oh, her favorite place.
Rio wants me so bad.
Hello everybody who came in.
This is a game, if you couldn't tell, where it is all voice controlled and it's very frustrating.
Yup, we're doing our best.
We're doing our best.
Safe.
Basically, we're in space and...
Aliens started attacking.
And...
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
Can that be...
Yeah, we have the numbers.
We have the...
Bookshelf.
Encyclopedias and accounting documents.
So we're trying to figure out what happened in the space station, basically.
Check above bookshelf.
Yeah.
Search above bookshelf.
Look above bookshelf.
No, there's not, Rio.
Top of bookshelf.
How does it feel to yell top at me and that doesn't work?
You yell, you say top, Vtuber.
Say top of bookshelf instead.
And it didn't work.
How does it feel?
How does it feel to be so confident and be so wrong?
Top Rio.
She's confused.
She doesn't understand.
TV.
Yeah, what is that?
Check monitor.
Yeah.
Wait, from the monitor room?
No, that's not our room.
It feels a lot like you feel talking to Rio.
What do you mean?
Backseating?
But I'm right.
I'm right.
What are you talking about?
I'm correct.
You guys are the ones saying say this instead and it's wrong.
Which one should I check?
Book.
Do you mean that?
Yeah.
Read notebook.
That's... check bed.
Look under sheets.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, she actually listened.
She listened.
Sexy pose?
Do a sexy pose.
What does she mean by that?
Amputated leg, sir?
It's the greatest day from a Homestar thing.
What?
I don't remember that at all.
Do a sexy pose.
Suicide.
Don't be stupid.
There are people who are counting on us.
She doesn't understand sexiness anymore.
No.
Let's see.
Search above bookshelf.
There were only encyclopedias and documents.
Top of bookshelf.
We got a teacher.
Do a double peace sign.
Peace, peace.
Check behind photos.
It's a men's bathrobe.
I think the manager was using it.
Behind photos.
Do you mean that?
Behind cards?
Above bookshelf.
There were only encyclopedias and documents.
On top of bookshelf.
You missed the sexy pose you can grab from the bookshelf.
Wait.
If you missed the sexy pose you...
Oh.
If you missed the sexy pose you can grab it from the bookshelf.
Right now this item can't be grabbed.
But it's shiny.
Miku-chan, I already tried.
Search on top of bookshelf, please.
Please.
But it's shiny.
Shouldn't I still be able to grab it?
Chat has old information.
Look at photos.
That's a good suggestion.
It's a men's bathrobe.
I think the manager was using it.
Is it really that we can't grab it?
Even though...
Even though it's shiny?
I feel like if we had gotten it before...
It shouldn't be there then, right?
Right, I feel...
I feel like it wouldn't be shiny otherwise.
Look at this photograph.
Grab...
Every time I want to grab...
Grab photos.
I think if I mention photos...
She only talks about the bathroom.
What does GameFAQ say?
That's a great question.
Let's check.
We are in the manager's office.
Let's see.
Notebook.
It doesn't say!
No way!
But also, was that the final?
It says...
It says tell her to check...
The pillow for the final chip.
I don't think we got the final...
I think I must have missed some chips.
No way!
Did I miss some chips?
Okay.
Open the safe.
Does that get us the bad end?
Yeah, I know.
Hold on.
I'm not good with these.
Oh.
Four.
Uh-huh.
Okay.
Yeah.
Six.
Is the last one two?
Wait.
Oh, it still worked.
Is that okay?
Two.
I don't know.
Oh!
Guys?
Wait a second.
Wait!
Just a hot minute.
Oh, you have to say four right.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Four right.
And then you have to say six left.
Okay.
Six left.
Wait.
I think you went the wrong way.
No!
Rio!
You did it wrong!
Two left.
Two.
Yeah, you blew it Rio.
You blew it.
Four right.
Yes.
Six left.
Nice.
Two right.
Yay!
We got it.
It opened.
Nice.
Rob him of all his worth.
Rob him for all his worth!
What is this disc?
It says lost and found on it.
It belongs to...
Alan Honda.
Hang on a minute.
She's zooming.
Go.
Go Rio.
Oh, I found a player.
This will let us watch that disc we found.
Good.
It doesn't appear to be broken.
We are still watching DVDs.
Maybe we went in a circle.
Maybe DVDs are trendy again.
So that's why we watch them.
Everybody wants physical media.
So in 2030, we all return to physical media.
What is that?
That says project Rio.
She can't listen.
I'm sorry.
Is the blue ball the Philosopher's Stone?
We are in FMA now.
This is it.
They made a bootleg.
That's different.
That's...
This very stone has been spared in order that your country may carry out its plan of battle.
And we believe that this is the only...
They made...
Oh my god!
It... Oh my god!
Have I been fighting flowers?
Joseph Craft?
Corrupt living creatures with curses.
We had WMD and a Stalin.
What do you mean just as I thought?
It was all baloney.
Load of malarkey.
Yeah!
Kill him!
We should curse him.
We have to curse him with the stone.
Curse him with the stone!
Guys, this is so bad.
We are about to go into a final boss fight.
We are so close to a final boss fight and we have no health.
Oh no!
This is so bad.
Save point.
What about the shiny thing?
I think I'm gonna give up.
It's ok.
I didn't even get all the chips.
I didn't get all the chips, so...
Do you have a heal?
I don't.
She used the last one.
In the last battle we just did.
When she didn't even need it.
She used it.
I wonder what all the chips do.
I think maybe they unlock something in the...
In the...
Extras menu is what I'm assuming.
I actually have no idea what they do.
Pull out a fuzzy wuzzy mid-combat, I wish.
Ok, we checked the shower booth.
We do have...
Three launcher grenades.
So that's pretty huge, I'm not gonna lie.
Look at that!
We were one chip away!
A trendy and popular collectible item.
Something happens every time four chips are collected.
We were one chip away.
Where did I miss it?
No way!
Where would it be?
I feel like I... I don't think it's the bookshelf.
Check...
The shiny is the last one.
No, I think that's a... I mean...
I will satiate everybody's...
If I'm wrong?
Awesome.
But... Bed.
Hello?
If I'm wrong, that's great.
But I think it's a command ticket.
I don't think it's a chip.
The bookshelf is a camera check command.
See?
It's a command ticket.
It's not a chip, you guys.
But I'll satiate your curiosity.
What is this anyway?
Product is not registered equipment.
How many chips?
I have 15 out of 16 in the game.
I don't know where I missed it though.
Check pictures.
Oh, maybe check pictures.
Check behind pictures.
Nope.
Check pictures.
Stop.
Yeah, I know.
Bookshelf.
Bed.
And we received a chip in the room from the bed.
It seems unlikely.
Yeah, I think...
You guys, I can even tell from the coloring.
That it's a command thing.
I give up.
Leave.
No, leave.
It does look like a nice bed though.
Leave.
Hallway.
Run.
I just don't know.
I feel like I've been so thorough with checking.
Categories game.
Rio picks up a category.
The first person to miss loses.
Where should I go?
Exhibit room.
The exhibit room.
Okay.
Categories would be so fun.
Run.
Do you also get health from that?
There's a hill behind the other door in the elevator room.
Wait, where is it?
Oh, that's right!
There was that other battle we totally...
We totally forgot about.
Well, I forgot about it.
I'll give it a try.
I didn't say.
Try the right one.
It didn't work.
Stupid Rio.
No.
It won't work.
She gives up so easily.
You okay Rio?
Is it worth having to do another annoying battle though?
To get a health kit.
Probably not.
Yeah.
Okay.
Get ready, set.
Did it work?
We did it at the same time.
Get ready, set.
Girl!
I did it when she said now!
Mito very cute.
Thanks Jane!
Thanks for 9 months!
Oh whoops.
I pressed the wrong thing.
Get ready, set.
We did it!
Rio.
We.
Rio, you can't take all the credit for this.
She's so rude.
lol
Wow!
Okay, save point.
I'm not going through all of this.
We are looking for a green stone.
Rio is so selfish.
You egotistical woman!
I thought we was your favorite word!
Oh wait, no?
Let's do this one.
Yeah.
Good!
It's always you failed or you messed up.
Yeah, or I did it but never we did it.
Okay, walk.
Alright, walk around.
Let's look around.
We are looking for...
Alright, we are in front of case 9.
8.
What is that big one right there?
Am I getting ambushed?
Yes I am.
Mouth!
Shoot!
Stomach!
Head!
Shoot!
Flee!
What else is in here?
Shoot!
Stomach!
Oh my god.
Shoot!
What the hell is that?
Enemy...
No, enemy 3.
Shoot!
Auto fire!
Nevermind.
Stomach!
Auto fire!
Oh, that worked actually.
Okay, nice.
Right eye!
Shoot!
Middle eye!
Actually no, vines!
Auto fire!
Reload!
Vines!
Move right!
I can't see anything.
Maybe we are okay here.
Auto fire!
Nope, okay.
Move right!
I wish I could see anything.
Vines!
Auto fire!
Reload!
Am I shooting anything?
It looks like it's got it's hand on it's hips.
Like it's annoyed at me.
Auto fire!
I don't know what I'm supposed to be shooting.
Branches!
What did you do?
I don't know!
Fuck off!
Move left!
Shoot!
Auto fire!
Am I hitting anything?
Oh my god.
Body!
Move left!
Dodge left!
Root!
Auto fire!
I think like tiniest bit ever.
What should I do?
Strafe!
Reload!
Oh that did well.
Strafe!
What should I do?
Reload!
Leave!
No.
Reload!
It's working a little.
Slowly but surely we are getting there.
What should I do?
And it doesn't hurt us from back here so that's kinda nice.
Strafe!
Yes!
No...
Dodge left!
Strafe!
Oh nice, nice, nice!
Nice!
Reload!
Strafe!
Why is it got it's hands on it's hips like that?
Reload!
Leave!
Nope.
Reload!
Yeah there you go.
Strafe!
Nice.
It's posing.
The sassiest alien.
The sassiest alien of all.
Is that case...
Wait.
We are in front of case 8?
Check case 7.
It looks kinda green.
Maybe it's the philosopher's stone.
Nope.
Okay.
Walk.
Strafe attacks...
Yeah, strafe attacks like kind of hit every point.
They like kind of like go through a bunch of different points.
So it's kinda... it's not so bad actually.
Another...
Oh it's this guy again.
Flee!
Okay.
Ai!
Damn it.
Jump!
Okay nevermind.
Goodbye.
Just gonna stand here.
I don't know.
Ai!
Jump!
She doesn't know where to look.
Run!
Jump!
Nice.
Ai!
I don't know if that did anything.
Flee!
Flee.
Jump!
Ai!
Oh nevermind.
Flee!
Oh it's gonna disappear in a second anyway.
Nevermind.
Jump!
Ai!
Flee!
Mouth!
Actually yeah you should do that.
Ai!
Shoot!
Turn around!
Jump!
Flee!
This monster is so difficult.
Ai!
Flee.
I might die here actually.
I might die.
This thing is so annoying.
Flee!
I might die.
Ai!
Turn around!
As soon as I turn around it disappears!
Ai!
Shoot!
Jump!
We'll have to do the first battle again.
That's okay.
That one wasn't as bad I suppose.
Also I was like walking over here.
I guess I could've maybe gone to the save point.
I don't know.
Okay.
Walk.
Yes.
Maybe go the other way.
I don't know.
Can't stop her from walking that direction.
You trying to finish today?
Oh yeah we'll finish today.
Mouth!
Shoot!
Auto fire!
Flee!
Mouth!
Shoot!
Jump back!
Mouth!
Auto fire!
Her aim is so bad.
Stomach!
Auto fire!
Reload!
Stomach!
Shoot!
Mouth!
Oh my god!
Flee!
No!
That way!
Not that way!
Oh my gosh!
Enemy 1!
Enemy 2!
Flee!
Oh my god!
Please!
I need you to run girl!
Enemy 2!
Flee!
I need you to get out of there!
There you go!
That's a good girl!
Enemy 3!
Jump back!
Jump!
Mouth!
I got that command!
I got the command jump back!
And she does not do it!
She goes jump and then she steps back!
I can't with her and her silly antics.
Anyway, sorry.
My eyes are bleeding.
I know, me too.
Thank you for the super chat though.
Jump back!
Mouth!
Back!
Auto-fire!
Mouth!
Head!
Stomach!
Auto-fire!
Mouth!
Stomach!
Auto-fire!
Reload!
No!
You're good!
Watch closely and don't reload!
Reload!
Back!
Stomach!
There we go.
Ok, ok, ok.
Turn around!
Ok.
Move right!
Strafe!
Reload!
Yeah, reload.
Move right!
Move right a little bit more.
Ok.
Strafe!
I wonder if that's the one that's hidden by the barrels.
But also reload.
And strafe.
Nope, strafe.
Uh, strafe?
Reload!
Spin gun!
Oh, I can't see anything now.
Where am I?
Move right!
No, no!
Turn around!
No!
Turn right!
Strafe!
Uh, move right!
We're getting it slowly but surely.
Reload!
Strafe!
Uh, move right!
Got her aim.
Reload!
Strafe!
Yeah, I feel like this way takes longer but at least I'm not getting hit.
What did you do that for?
Where are you going?
That was my fault.
Move left!
No, there we go.
Strafe!
Oh, my bad.
I didn't realize she wasn't loaded.
Strafe!
Reload!
I think it's the eyes that are the weak point, but...
Like, if I do the leaves, I think it shows the eyes and then those are the weak points.
Strafe!
It's almost dead though.
That's okay.
Strafe!
Well, she didn't do that, you know?
If she didn't do that, it would be okay, you know?
Save point.
No, save point.
Alright, we'll save.
We're saving.
Goodbye Observatory Restaurant.
Actually, well, that last fight was not ideal because I did get attacked by the stinking slimes.
The stinking slugs a couple of times, but that's okay.
The way we have to save after every battle.
The way we have to save after everything that we do.
You can't skip the cutscenes, so if there's a cutscene you want to save after that, you can't.
It's just insanity.
Alright, get up.
Let's check...
Case 9.
Oh, she's going all the way around.
Around town.
Oh, just kidding.
I was at the wrong spot.
That's confusing!
Case 2.
I thought she was going...
Hyper protein.
Wow, get those for working out.
Oh, wait, what?
Mouth.
Flea.
Oh, this is not so bad.
Head.
Stomach.
Shoot.
Sure.
Oh, there's another one over there.
Strafe.
Leaf.
See, I think if I go for the leaves...
And then I uncover the eyes...
If she doesn't hit the leaf, it sucks.
So, just strafing ends up being the better option, I think.
Anyway.
Strafe.
Enemy 3.
Enemy...
Mouth.
Shoot.
Strafe.
Reload.
Mouth.
Stomach.
Back.
Flea.
No, no, wrong way, wrong way, wrong way, wrong way.
Wrong way, wrong way.
Flea.
Enemy 1.
Enemy 2.
Turn around.
Flea.
Oh my god.
Strafe.
Holy cow.
Move left.
Strafe.
Nice.
Reload.
Move left.
Strafe.
Enemy 3.
Mouth.
Shoot.
Oh, nevermind.
Flea.
Good, good, good, good.
Good, good.
Shoot.
Stomach.
Head.
Mouth.
Stomach.
Shoot.
Auto-fire.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, okay, okay.
Move right.
Oh my gosh, it's almost dead.
Strafe.
Wait, does that mean I don't have to fight the...
the...
other thing?
That's huge, if so.
Save point.
Run.
Nevermind.
We just got ambushed.
Right eye.
Left eye.
Middle eye.
Shoot.
Auto-fire.
Red eye.
Body.
Wait.
Mouth.
Flea.
What the hell?
It chased...
Tail.
Auto-fire.
No.
Tail.
Mouth.
Oh my gosh.
Auto-fire.
That was good.
Flea.
It doesn't... Tail.
Tail.
Shoot.
Another one?
What is it?
I don't even know what it is.
Oh my gosh, it's the same fucking thing.
Right eye.
Left eye.
Middle eye.
Red eye.
Mouth.
Body.
Wait.
Flea.
No, I can't avoid that.
It's so annoying.
Tail.
Please let that be it.
You guys, I can't heal.
This is so upsetting.
Oh my gosh, there is no way to interrupt it because...
It's moving and you can't shoot it's body because it's hard.
And if you shoot it's tail, it's behind it.
So there is no way to do that.
There is no way to do that.
The tail.
She will miss the tail.
100%.
Oh gosh.
Oh man.
Move right.
I'll save.
Dodge left.
He doesn't stop.
Tail.
Turn around.
Right eye.
We are about to die you guys.
We are about to die and we are going to have to do this all over again.
Hold on, I want to see what this room is like because why am I getting different things?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh shit.
Okay, there is a lot of stuff here.
Run!
Which one was it?
This one.
I don't know how we are going to get through this room with no health.
Oh shit.
I don't know.
She sells.
Yep.
Let's just sell.
Yeah.
Yes.
Okay.
Oh shit.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, maybe we can jump.
We can try.
She stood on the balcony inexplicably mimicking him hiccuping and amicably welcoming him in.
Yeah, I wonder... I'm pretty... I'm almost positive it was jump back.
Right?
The command that I had was jump back command.
But that thing follows me until I stop running.
Which... like it doesn't like go for a little bit at least from what I know.
At least from how we've done it.
Thank you Legado!
Thanks for 10 months!
Thank you.
Let's see.
The dodge wouldn't... didn't work.
Number one.
Oh.
Flee.
Approach.
Recover.
Dodge.
Forward.
Oh wait, where the hell is it?
Jump back.
Yeah, so it was jump back.
But all she does is she jumps in place and then goes back.
I think we could still get the heal left behind but I don't...
I don't want to go fight that.
I don't... whoopsie.
I don't want to go fight anything else.
I also looked it up.
It's case 3 that we need to get to.
Case... whoops.
Case 3.
Is the important one.
Oh, stop.
Stop!
Save point.
I want to save since we just healed.
So at least if I die and come back we can at least have full health from the get go.
Have you tried telling her get good?
That's a great command.
They should add that to the game.
Get good Rio and then she... wait there should be a lock in Rio.
There should be a lock in and then she's like OK.
There should be a lock in Rio.
Alright, case 3.
I just don't know how many things we are having to fight.
Like truly, especially because it's switching around.
Mouth.
Auto fire.
Flea.
Woo!
Stomach.
Enemy 3.
Mouth.
It doesn't work Rio if you miss.
Rio it doesn't work if you miss.
Rio we can't win if you miss.
Rio wouldn't miss a shot if she just locked in.
That's what I'm saying.
I think the programmers of this game are evil for allowing you to...
Like what is the percentage of her missing?
I wonder.
What is the percentage of her like missing the shot every time.
Strafe.
Oh shit.
Jump back.
She didn't even go back.
Flea.
Strafe.
Thank you for the raid.
Stomach.
Flea.
Oh no.
Oh shit.
Enemy 2.
Flea.
Run away from that thing first.
No.
Flea.
Enemy 1.
Turn around.
Stomach.
Reload.
Shoot.
Auto fire.
Mouth.
Back.
Reload.
Dodge right.
Head.
Mouth.
Auto fire.
Stomach.
Okay.
Nice.
Reload.
Turn around.
I know.
Can you imagine having to find ammo in this game?
Right.
Move right.
No.
That's not what I said.
Where are you going?
Move right.
No.
There we go.
Okay.
Strafe.
Reload.
You can do a barrel roll.
I wish.
Strafe.
Yeah.
We are in the end game.
Strafe.
Can we?
Can we move on?
Are we actually able to move on?
Hurry.
Oh gosh.
Case 3.
Right eye.
Middle eye.
Left eye.
Shoot.
Reload.
Jump.
Tail.
Red eye.
Body.
See if I shoot the body, you guys.
Flee.
Trying to make a point.
Doesn't work.
Shooting the body does nothing.
Mouse.
Auto fire.
Reload.
Oh man.
Flee.
Nice, nice, nice.
Dodge right.
Tail.
Shoot.
Oh my gosh.
Reload.
Shoot.
Dodge right.
Right eye.
Left eye.
Middle eye.
Red eye.
Mouse.
Mouth.
I wish we could get something like the first boss with the spider where I really only had to time it.
The final boss is going to be absolute hell.
No heal.
No grenades.
We are
going to actually go through it.
I might actually quit.
I don't know yet.
I don't know.
I might actually quit.
Tail.
I don't...I'm trying to.
Dodge right.
Tail.
Here he comes.
Left eye.
Right eye.
Shoot.
Left eye.
Middle eye.
Shoot.
Oh, OK.
Yeah, that's good.
Shoot.
Red eye.
Mouth.
Auto fire.
Oh shit.
OK.
Flee.
What the hell?
What is this?
I can't see anything.
Tail.
Flee.
Oh shoot.
Dodge right.
Dodge left.
Tail.
Shoot.
Oh, reload.
Damn it.
Shoot.
Oh, did we get it?
Oh my god.
Yeah.
Save point.
Actually, stop.
She sells.
Just in case.
Yes.
What was it?
Ted threw Fred three free throws.
Oh my god.
OK.
Sheep shouldn't sleep in a shack.
Sheep should sleep in a shed.
She needs to get like new tongue twisters.
Repeat after me.
Betty Batter had some butter.
But she said this butter's bitter.
If I bake this butter butter, it would make my batter bitter.
OK, your turn.
Betty Batter had some butter.
But she said this butter's bitter.
If I bake this bitter butter, it would make my batter bitter.
Awesome.
Her tongue twisters are old, Mia.
Thanks.
I really needed that.
Alright, one more.
She sells.
Yes.
Drop the beat.
Ragged rascal ran.
Around the rugged rocks, the ragged rascal ran.
Awesome.
She is so tiny, huh?
A noise annoys an oyster.
But a noisy noise annoys an oyster more.
OK, your turn.
A noise annoys an oyster.
But a noisy noise annoys an oyster more.
Awesome.
Repeat after me.
How much wood would a woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck could chuck wood?
A woodchuck would chuck as much as he could chuck if a woodchuck could.
OK, your turn.
How much wood would a woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck could chuck wood?
A woodchuck would chuck as much as he could chuck if a woodchuck could.
Awesome.
Hello?
How much wood would a woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck could chuck wood?
A woodchuck would chuck as much as he could chuck if a woodchuck could.
Not bad.
Wow, you did it.
Thanks.
Finally an action game tougher than DMC3.
Where are we anyway?
We are so close to case 3 and we are very far from save point.
So I am very scared.
But we will still try to save.
Save point.
Can't imagine how you will play this game if you never knew about the tongue twister heal mechanic.
I actually would have given up.
I would have actually 100% given up.
Anti-JRPG.
Instead of preparing for the boss battle, Ryo spends everything she did.
I don't think it would be possible.
Like... I don't know.
I don't know.
They... I don't know.
I have no idea.
Wait.
I have to.
Even though she wasted a grenade.
She wasted a grenade on a guy who had 2 health.
She really is just throwing.
I truly believe.
Case 3.
I wonder if we have gotten everything though.
I guess we will see.
I don't know if we have fought everything.
If we did, that's pretty cool.
That would be really splendid and grand.
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
We made it!
The music is a bop.
What?
What does that mean?
Is that a bomb?
P-B-X This amalgam of high...
Oh.
I can't.
Time fuse.
The time fuse can be turned off by entering passcodes.
Enter the sum of the last digits of today's date.
The sum of the last digits of today's date.
Today is like my computer date.
Wait.
Hold on.
The sum of the last digits.
Wait.
No, no, no.
It's 12.
It was Christmas.
So 25.
What's the year?
30?
I don't know.
15?
15.
Enter the sum of the last digits of today's date.
If it's so easy, then do it.
2, 4, 9, 15.
15, right?
Am I right?
Am I correct?
15.
Sorry.
Oh my gosh.
Yes.
Enter the number of guests checked into the hotel.
OK.
She told me.
13.
I'm working on it.
What?
It's not?
Rio, you almost had us.
You told us to check carefully and you almost had us exploded.
Right now.
Tanaka's note.
50 guests.
I got it.
Fuse.
It won't let me select it.
It won't let me select it for real.
How do I select it?
Oh there we go.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
I had to press triangle.
OK.
Enter the sum of the last digits of PM Takayama's birthday.
Oh.
What's that?
How are we supposed to know the Prime Minister's birthday?
I don't know.
What do we do?
Me this entire stream.
It's hopeless.
I don't know his birthday.
What do I do?
We came so close.
Guess we die.
I have no idea.
It's OK.
We got this.
Let's go ask him.
I am?
I did?
He did?
Oh my god.
Detective Conan over here.
Bazinga!
OK GameFAQs.
Do your thing.
GameFAQs.
He said something about that.
Let's see.
Tell her to check the DVD.
It has footage of his birthday.
It does?
It's today and he's 60.
I didn't tell her that at all.
What?
GameFAQs.
How am I supposed to...
What?
Wait.
Let me tell her.
Check the DVD.
Check video disc.
Video disc.
DVD.
Check the DVD.
Search video disc.
Check the CD.
Check...
Footage.
OK.
Fuck this.
I'm going with GameFAQs.
What did they tell me?
They told me...
What is it?
Summon this thing?
Character insert is 15.
We're speedrunning.
Useless.
You're useless.
Useless Ryo.
So useless.
I wonder if I have to throw that into the final monster's mouth, I imagine, right?
Because it's a bomb.
Don't drop it.
Oh my gosh, Ryo.
Yeah.
I thought you'd never ask.
Ryo, I'm so tired.
So sentimental all of a sudden.
My guide said to relax.
I know.
Yeah, you would be.
For 100%.
100% you would be dead.
1000%.
Can you imagine Ryo in a long distance relationship?
Hello, boyfriend.
Should I brush my teeth today?
This is such a death flag.
Oh, death flag.
Of course.
If we get back.
This is someone's death flag.
It's either hers or mine.
Wee woo, wee woo.
We haven't heard from her in a long time.
We haven't heard from her in a really long time, Ryo.
Woah!
Holy mother of...
Oh she's back!
Our guns are useless against her.
Oh yeah!
Does that count as a save?
I would hope so.
They weren't a rescue team.
They're after the stone too.
The Philosopher's Stone!
She who shall not be named.
She's running.
I'm gonna keep running.
Keep running.
The Philosopher's Legacy.
Shit her?
Number 2 in her mouth!
A rocket on a person?
Not a human.
Shut her panel.
Close.
Oh no, it didn't work.
What is that?
Red.
Red lever.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Shoot red lever.
Nice.
Yeah.
Ok.
Shoot red lever.
Nice.
Shoot yellow lever.
I can't speak.
Oh no, no, no.
Wait.
Shoot red lever.
I think I have to go for the red.
Oh my gosh.
No, no, no.
Shoot red lever.
Ouch.
Stop!
Guys, I'm confused.
Am I doing this right?
What the hell is happening?
I think I have to shoot whatever is on top, right?
Are they shooting it too?
Oh my God.
I think I'm getting it.
Shoot yellow lever.
Shoot yellow.
Yes.
Shoot yellow lever.
There we go.
No!
Shoot yellow lever.
Oh, I think we got it.
Oh my gosh, finally.
Shoot soldiers.
Seriously though.
Gosh.
Okay.
True.
Good thinking.
Wow, Rio used a brain cell for once.
Seriously?
Now is not the time.
Oh, Gino is about to die.
Uh-oh.
No!
Bye, Gino.
Gino is dead meat.
Convince Gino.
Run.
Wait, seriously?
No!
This is... No, girl.
Girl, don't.
Are you serious?
It's gonna kill us and then I'm gonna have to do all of that over again.
No!
Please!
RIP Gino.
No!
I really do have to do all of that over again.
Are you kidding me?
I tried to tell her.
It was such a small amount of time.
You guys, it's such a small amount of time.
I'll just tell her to run.
Case 3.
Oh my gosh, I have to do all of this again too.
Run.
I have to do all of the inputs again too.
What was it?
15...
15, 15, 15, 15, 15, 15.
Why didn't you save?
What the fuck?
Seriously, Lumen?
Lumen?
Seriously?
Tell me what opportunity it gave me to save.
Huh?
Tell me.
Tell me right now.
And you better be correct!
I'm waiting.
I'm waiting for your response in chat.
I'm calling you out.
This can't be.
Listen, can you analyze this device?
Yeah.
The time fused can be shut down by entering 3 numerical past dates.
It's so fast.
Enter the sum of the last digits of today's date.
Under where?
What's the first one?
Enter the sum of the last digits of today's date.
I'm still waiting for your answer.
Like a coward?
Afraid of being wrong?
OK!
It's 15.
Chat...I write it wrong.
Enter the number of guests checked into the hotel.
No it's not.
It's 50 and I'm going to put that in.
Don't worry Rio.
I know you're stupid.
Don't worry.
I know you're a dummy.
No!
Lumen is looking at guys to see if there really is a save point.
Scanning through every forum post from 2004.
There has to be something.
Some place to save.
Somewhere.
Lumen, all you have to do is apologize.
OK?
Enter the sum of the last digits of PM Takayama's birthday.
I know it.
I'm from the future.
Rio I'm from the future!
Let me handle it.
Shut up.
DVD
Didn't he...didn't he say something about that at some point?
Yes.
Will you apologize?
OK!
Thank you!
I'm crying.
I'm sorry.
Are you crying?
Are you crying Lumen?
Have mercy on me!
Beg!
Beg Lumen!
Beg for your mercy!
Beg for it!
On all knees!
I got it.
I wish I could skip some of these cutscenes for real.
OK.
I wonder if I could.
Options?
No.
Sometimes I think Chiara is right.
There should be a usual room for us, for you guys too.
We should have a usual room on stream.
Can you skip the ones that don't involve talking?
You unfortunately cannot.
So, I'm gonna go get some more water.
While she's...oh wait, she's gonna talk to us, right?
OK, nevermind.
I'm hungry.
Rio, can I get a snack?
Yeah, Chiara has a room called the usual room where all good and bad KFP go.
For special treatment.
I'm gonna be snacking.
I've got some corn.
I've got some dried corn.
Crunchy corn.
I'm gonna eat it.
I'm sure Naomi is safe somewhere.
We'll find her.
We've got to.
What are you doing?
Put that back!
Why are you destroying the station?
That's none of your concern.
I knew there was something weird.
You guys aren't a rescue team.
Pipe down and hand that over.
Holy mother of...
Alright.
Sexy lady incoming.
Give us a show, man.
I would love some curry.
Those men, I knew it.
They weren't a rescue team.
This chat is too down bad.
Can you blame us?
I didn't think it would take this long to finish beating the game, you guys.
I was a fool.
I thought it would take like 6 hours about.
Dang it.
Oh well.
Lifeline watchers have been through a lot.
Yeah, give us at least a little bit of something.
You think I'm making good time?
Really?
I closed it.
Alright, this part is silly.
I'm gonna have to look up what the new game plus outfits are.
Shoot red lever.
Nice.
Yeah, I know.
I'm from the future.
Shoot red lever.
Shoot yellow lever.
Oh, shoot yellow lever.
Now?
Oh no!
You bastards!
Shoot red lever.
Shoot red lever!
Shoot yellow lever!
Ah, we got it.
Nice!
Which lever boss?
The red lever!
Okay, here we run away.
Run, run, run!
Run away!
Go!
Leave!
Don't try to seduce her!
She's... she's not available.
She's not looking for a one-time fling.
She's...
Thief!
Come on, thief!
Rio, I'm disappointed with you.
I'm disappointed with you.
Voice acting sometimes leaves something to be desired.
This boss is all powerful.
How the hell are we supposed to beat her?
Damn it, what is this thing?
Don't shoot!
Let me go!
Operator, run away!
Bye!
Bye Gino!
See you never!
See you never ever again!
Bye bye!
You can reason with her.
He threw his red stomach.
Holy cow!
Hold on, I'm gonna look for if there's a save point.
I'm kind of using the game facts a lot right now because I don't want to die.
Really badly.
So, sorry if I'm relying on it a bit.
Uh oh.
Are they gonna murder all of them?
Are
they gonna shoot them all?
Uh oh!
Oh dear.
Dun dun!
Oh!
Alan!
Oh.
Alan Conn.
Why are games so bad at music leveling?
So bad.
Oh!
Oh
my god!
Exactly.
Here's my evil plan.
Oh damn!
Oh shit!
They just created a bad, bad ghost!
Oh!
Or that thing.
They created a sea monster.
Sea monkey!
I don't
want to fight that thing.
Ripperoni!
But she won't touch us, right?
We didn't do anything.
Oh, is she dying now?
Oh, in her final...
Wow!
Let's go wife!
Yeah!
Everybody is dead.
That bakery...
Stop!
She just died.
Yes.
Yeah I did.
From many camera angles.
Oh, take his
laptop.
See ya Alan!
You were a spineless little weasel anyway.
Such a lust for revenge.
What?
What did you know?
Rio, do you think?
Rio, what did you know?
Okay.
I'm a descendant of Parakelsis.
The scientist from Alan's soul.
What?
The story of Parakelsis and the Philosopher's Stone is more than just a legend.
It's real.
She's a descendant of him?
It's the stone that I've been trying to find.
It's an heirloom that my family has guarded since Parakelsis time.
Excuse me?
It began to influence my life when I was only a child.
Dad began studying the Philosopher's Stone with a geologist he hired.
That man was probably the one...
The geologist's name was Joseph Craft.
I can't believe she saw it!
Those two spent years researching the stone.
And they eventually uncovered the secret nature of it.
Boredom.
Physically, the Philosopher's Stone is pretty much your basic rock.
But what's uncanny about it is the composition.
Completely uniform throughout.
Whether stone or metal, it's impossible to manufacture solids of entirely uniform composition on Earth.
I can't believe it!
Because of gravity.
Gravity.
The same night they concluded their analysis of the stone, Craft shot my dad.
No!
You were one of the Philosopher's this entire time!
No, don't make me Rio.
I'm Operator.
I'm not Rio.
He also shot me.
What?
He shot you?
Is that why you can take a bullet so well?
Damn.
Aw, Rio.
Yeah,
Rio.
Legacy of the Philosopher's.
Yeah, take that disc.
It's our evidence.
Guard it with your life.
Is she gonna die?
You think?
She'll join her family.
She's gonna die with the Philosopher's Stone, isn't she?
Hopefully.
It will be such sweet.
But then...
But then everything we've done would be for nothing.
She's at least cute.
Just extremely stupid.
Chat is ruthless.
We've been through a lot.
I don't get it.
What were they gonna do with it?
Turn people into hideous monsters?
He would use the stone for that?
Yeah, people are evil.
He'd use the stone for that.
Let's stop him.
God, I'm just babbling now.
But whatever happens, the craft is finished.
Yeah, you could say he's macaroni and cheese.
And Naomi.
Yeah.
You think she's still alive?
Listen.
That was pretty cheesy of you.
In spite of all our searching, we haven't found your girlfriend.
What are you trying to say, huh?
You know what's happening, right?
You think Naomi is the sexy lady?
That alien?
Win-win.
Or is it some kind of mutated person that's chasing us?
Yeah.
And you think?
Could it be?
Oh.
I'm sorry.
What am I saying?
Oh my gosh.
There's still the testing ward left.
That's it.
She must be in the testing ward.
Oh.
The monitor room you're in, it's in the testing ward.
She may have been right next to you this entire time.
Maybe.
Naomi's safe.
I'm sure of it.
Maybe.
The three of us can leave this place together.
I'll go get her now.
Naomi is me.
I can get to the testing ward on the elevator.
Wait for me.
Okay.
Is there a safe point in this elevator perchance?
Or you know?
I knew there was a safe point.
Oh gosh.
Please let there be a safe point.
Please.
Let there be a safe point.
We've gone through way too many cut scenes for me to do this again.
The mouth of the beast.
Okay.
What about fighting?
Which hopefully we don't have to do in here.
Right?
We're saving at the safe point.
And the safe point?
I'm not going to let that go.
Miss Rio.
Rio, grab it.
I thought you had great reflexes.
Okay.
There is none.
I'm checking the guide.
One moment please.
Where are we?
Actually.
It is not telling me...
Hold on.
Rio continues down the hall.
First tell Rio to go to hatch 1.
Open it and there's...
Okay.
It's not telling me in the game facts if there's any monsters in here.
I'm...
I'm hoping that there is no ambush.
It's not telling me that there's any...
It's only telling me to go to hatch 1.
Hatch 1.
Okay.
Bye!
See ya!
Where is hatch 1?
Oh, it's right here?
Okay.
Open.
Where are we?
I'm checking.
Hold on.
Hatch 5.
There's a heal.
Apparently 2 leads to the laboratory.
Sorry, hold on.
I'm really checking this up and down because I'm too nervous.
I'm too nervous about getting ambushed.
I have no idea.
Anyway.
It's telling me only to go to hatch 2.
But what's in hatch 4 and 6?
And hatch 3?
Is it like a maze?
Is that what this is?
Hatch 2.
I don't know.
Death.
Okay, we won't go there then.
I'm following the guide because I'm too scared.
I'm too scared to do it.
Guys, it'll be like 45 minutes of stuff we'd have to repeat.
This is not a time to risk it for the biscuit.
This is a time to be safe than sorry.
This is not a time.
I'm being as cautious as I can be.
Hatch 2.
Resi, I should time you out for that.
Alright.
Save point.
Hallelujah.
Okay.
Now...
Alright, so what do we got here?
We can go back and check.
Let's go check.
Hatch 3.
Let's go see what the other parts are.
Wait.
JJ.
Oh, just kidding.
Oh, she's flipping.
Do a flip!
No, that's not one.
That's okay, you tried.
Sample cases.
Top case.
No, it's a slug.
Yeah, take a picture.
Middle case.
Bottom case.
That one's alive!
Storage booths.
Sexy pose.
Yeah, let's try.
Do a sexy pose.
No, stop.
Stop.
Nevermind.
I give up.
Storage booths.
You probably felt as if a ton just got off your shoulders.
I know!
The other ton will probably leave when you're done with the game.
Absolutely.
Check left booth.
Booths.
What is that?
Machine?
I don't know what to say.
No, it's the full phrase.
Do a sexy pose.
I think.
I don't know.
Lever.
Lock lever.
That won't open anything, will it?
Panel.
Yellow.
Yellow panel?
I don't know.
What is that?
It's a machine.
What are those up there?
I have no idea.
Storage booths?
Okay, well then...
Check...
Check first machine.
I have no idea what they're called.
Control panel.
Yeah, there we go.
I think there's...
Oh.
I don't want to let anything out.
What are those called?
Lockers?
Locker.
No.
Stop.
Storage booths.
Are they not called booth?
Booth.
No.
Closet.
Storage rack.
Oh my god.
Check first storage rack.
Why is it called a storage booth then?
Check second storage rack.
Check third storage rack.
Okay.
What about the...
Check third storage rack.
That one's open.
Oh, that one's the last one, I think.
Check open storage rack.
No.
Check second storage rack.
Check storage rack second to right.
Ah, we did it.
Then...
Okay, never mind.
Okay, that's fine.
Experiment rack one.
Yeah.
Whole lot of nothing.
These look like test systems.
Everything around this pillar seems to be...
Buttons.
Yup.
Control panel.
Use control panel.
Using a huge machine like this is way out of my league.
It's all you.
Okay.
I don't know if you want that.
Arm.
Oh my gosh, it's a drill.
What's the other one?
Experiment rack two.
Wish there was a chip in here.
Oh my god!
What is that?
Is that a worm?
Is that a slug?
Yellow.
I don't know.
Purple.
No.
Stop.
Experiment rack two.
What is it?
Is it a shoe?
Oh it is a shoe.
Shoe.
High heel.
High heel shoe.
Yes there is.
Look up.
Thank you.
Gosh.
Floating thingy.
Is that Naomi's foot?
I mean shoe.
I recognize that.
That's my girlfriend's shoe.
Was Naomi here?
Was she part of it?
You don't think.
You don't think she was part of this do you?
And she is just as bad as...
All Naomi's are bad.
Oh no!
Let's not get ahead of ourselves first though.
Experiment...
Oh, just kidding.
What is she doing?
Liquid nail.
Why was she like that?
Experiment rack three.
A whole lot of nothing.
Ok, nevermind.
Sorry guys, I'm getting sleepy.
Storage booths.
I'm getting sleepy sleepy.
I feel we are almost done with the game.
I think there is just this area and then the final boss.
Can I control?
Turn on device.
Oh wait.
Pull lever.
Yeah, pull it.
Pull the lever Rio.
I don't know.
We've checked everything in here.
Wrong lever.
Hold on, I'm checking game facts.
I'm getting so tired.
Wait.
Oh no, we do have another area I think.
Identify four storage racks which have nothing in them so ignore them.
Tell her to lock lever.
Oh, lock lever.
Check control device.
There we go.
Okay.
Check em.
I'm operating, I'm operating.
Message panel.
On.
Ejected into space?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Tell me a number.
Let's see.
2-1 Oh no, it's 3-1-4
It's going to reset itself.
Rio?
Let's see.
27 and 6 5 Pound pound Oh no.
Just one pound.
It's going to-
Girl?
Let's see.
3-8-7 And 5 and 1
That was- That was giving her a chance to correct herself?
Let's see.
Star star pound star pound pound And star star Star star pound Say it again?
No!
Stop!
Pound pound star star pound Release code entry time out.
Please try again.
You blew it.
Let's see.
7-2 and It's 7-1-8 5-4 Please proceed.
You guys want to do the last one for me?
2-7-8 Star and 9 If you write it in the chat it would really help.
The last one.
Let's see.
Pound star 5 star And 9 Release code acknowledged.
Please proceed.
Let's see.
Star star pound star pound pound And star star Star star pound star Pound pound star 5-4-3 Is this it?
1.
Incorrect.
Release code.
Please try again.
You blew it.
We have to start all over again.
Get it together.
Oh, it's 2 stars at the end.
Rio, why do you say that one so fast?
You're such a rude You're such an egotistical woman.
Let's see.
2-1 Oh no, it's 3-1-4
Please proceed.
Let's see.
27 and 6 5 pound pound Oh, no.
Just one pound.
5.
Release code acknowledged.
Please proceed.
Let's see.
3-8 7 5 1 Release code acknowledged.
Please proceed.
Let's see.
2-5 star 4-5 star 6 -1 God, that one's long.
5.
Release code acknowledged.
Please proceed.
Okay.
Let's see.
1-0-0 and 1 pound star and 2-2 Pound star 2-2 Release code acknowledged.
Please proceed.
More?
How many more are there?
3-4-6 5-8 Star 4-2 5.
All release codes acknowledged.
It seems to have worked.
Hang on for a second.
Oh my gosh!
We didn't have to star-pound, star-star-pound, pound-ground-pound, star-star-pound.
Yay!
Thanks for everybody who posted in the chat.
Though I actually didn't need it that time.
Must maintain a safe distance.
Okay.
Get launched into space!
No, I did it Rio.
I did it Rio, actually.
No, actually I really think the exact opposite.
She leaves, she doesn't let me save!
I did everything Rio!
Oh my
God.
The brain.
Scraping.
I'm Mito.
This game is so...
Freaky.
It's like opposite Hal.
Is that her dad, you think?
That's a massive brain.
That's bigger than her head.
If that's her dad...
She didn't inherit anything from him.
Oh.
Unless it's the guy that killed her father.
Then she gets to kill the guy that killed her family.
What?
What if it's her dad too?
Alright, turn off the cons.
What?
Ah yeah.
No way.
It was her dad!
There is a girl in Japan named Rio.
Are you ok?
Are you sure?
Hey dad.
Will you share the money?
Will you share the money with us?
You're about to be a millionaire.
The Julienaire Rio.
Will you share us the money?
We have to remember who got you out of the situation.
Signed, Alan Honda.
Ok.
Dad.
I think we deserve a reward money for helping her get out of this mess.
Uh oh.
Is this the thing?
Wait, is this thing powering the station?
Uh oh.
What does that mean?
Correcting anomaly in orbital trajectory.
Uh oh.
Angular adjustment complete.
Are we crashing?
Ah!
I was going to say are we about to crash into Earth?
Point of impact.
35 degrees, 40 minutes north latitude, 139 degrees, 45 minutes east longitude.
Tokyo, Japan.
Not Japan!
Dad!
I'm not a gold digger.
I don't want a relationship with her.
I just want a reward money for helping her get out of this situation.
Save point.
Nice.
Ok.
Wait, what?
Uh, save point?
What's happening?
Do I have a save point?
Wait, am I going to be controlling my own guy?
Am I controlling my body?
No, never mind.
No save point for us.
Oh!
She was waiting for us.
Huh?
Have you seen what?
It is Naomi!
Is she also becoming sexy?
Calm down!
Oh shit, I don't want to die here, sorry.
What do you tell her?
Sorry guys, I'm not about to go through all of that again.
Um...
Sorry.
What do I tell her?
Oh, I have to say anything.
Ok, cool.
Rio!
She hears me!
She hears me from...
Naomi!
Don't touch her.
Naomi...
No Naomi, you're so sexy!
Don't die!
No!
Aw...
Naomi...
She was good this whole time!
What happened to her?
She became invisible.
My girlfriend is dead.
She got Capri sunned.
No!
Am I...
Am I cursed?
They all died.
Oh no, she's Autocon!
Command, I couldn't save anyone.
Could everything...
Could it all be because of me?
Uh, maybe.
You really believe that?
No.
This is all... I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry to have gotten you and everyone else involved in this horrible mess.
There's no way for me to repair the damage I've caused.
No, it's ok.
Don't worry.
But Naomi asked me to save you.
Yeah.
She said, do you really believe that?
And I said, nah.
I will save you.
Will you wait for me?
We're trauma bonded now.
I'll wait for you.
I don't think this girl can live without me.
She has no survival instincts.
Yeah, we've definitely noticed that.
Why did she die?
I don't get it.
Maybe they have a small life span or something?
Maybe because they're unstable creatures?
The music.
Haha!
Wait, did that kill all the monsters?
Oh that's why!
The brain!
His mouth is really freaking me out.
Oh my god!
They're all floating around.
What is up, anyone?
All she was doing was asking for her boyfriend.
Yeah, that's me.
Yep, I'm here.
Hi!
I'll surely die.
I'm the one who locked him in the monitor room.
I've been poisoned by a caterpillar!
No!
I'm poisoned by a caterpillar!
So it was you who altered the station's orbit?
What's wrong with his eyes?
Oh my god!
What?
Are we a mutant too?
Wait, she is a robot?
Get yankered!
No way!
I got poisoned by a weedle.
Maybe she's not a robot, maybe she's just like Iron Man, right?
I can't!
This is so awesome!
That's the Philosopher's Stone!
Ah!
Oh my god!
She's the stone!
Yeah, it's a fake.
I'm seeing it right now.
Homoculai?
Homoculus?
Wait, homoculai is plural, right?
I'm dying of worm poisoning!
Oh
my god!
I've become a worm!
Can we go back and save?
Hatch 3.
Yeah, I'm going in there to save.
Real quick.
Save point.
Well, if you have a Philosopher's Stone and you are able to heal all your wounds, then why haven't you been needing healing packs?
Should have used a ground type.
Oh my goodness gracious.
Do I need any of these other things?
I don't think so anymore.
Alright, I think we go fight the final boss now.
Whatever that is, I have no idea.
I thought it was going to be what turned out to be Naomi.
Would you still love the Operator if he was a worm?
The final boss time, whatever that is.
Hatch 3.
This game is a wild ride.
We got like space and magic.
It's great.
We got space magic.
There she goes all on her own.
Oh, I can't talk?
Look at her go.
Now we know why some enemies have glowing weak spots that need to be shot to kill them.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
The reason why you can't have a Philosopher's Stone is if you die and get revived, you become stupid.
It's true.
Hatch 6.
She's on a mission.
I don't need to tell her what to do anymore.
Oh, okay.
The stone is already activated via tongue twister.
This is so cool.
Do you think we are going to be floating in the final battle?
I might be upset about that.
Good morning Ryo and other person.
Glen Jammin, thanks for 10 pounds.
Oh my god!
It's a whole birthing place of fake stones.
Too many fake stones.
Take them out!
Take it out Ryo!
Take it out!
All your anger.
Also, we only have probably 20 minutes left or so until we crash into Earth.
What can we do?
Don't cut yourself.
What do we do?
Something.
Who programs them?
Why?
In case it all goes really to shit, I guess.
What's what?
What's this?
That's where I am.
Am I the final boss?
Yes.
What was the point of the bomb then?
Of course.
Why was I zooming in?
I'm a caterpillar!
This guy was still alive!
Ah man!
Man!
A set of nuclear weapons.
This game has the philosopher's stone.
Ah man!
What?
I did?
I'm a worm?
I'm a worm!
She said something there.
I couldn't understand it.
I'm losing my capability of human speech.
Shoot him now!
Yeah, yeah.
Good idea.
Good, good Rio.
Don't hesitate.
Kill!
Shoot!
Wow!
You'll need the left joystick.
I will?
No!
What the?
I can't understand your accent.
Eww!
I don't want to fight this.
OK!
Wait, do I just glide?
Is that what I'm doing?
What's going on?
Am I moving?
Not shooting?
Rio is a free thinker now.
She doesn't need me.
He's gotta squeeze his fat ass through the tube first.
I'll forgive being evil scientist, but not misogyny!
Yeah!
We draw the line at evil whore!
Fall?
OK!
No way!
Wait, but what about... how do I use that to leave as well?
Wait, you're escaping?
And without me, right?
Wait...
Alright.
OK.
Wait, but turning it on makes it go.
Oh no, he's invisible.
I don't like that.
Oh my god and he's bigger!
What are you mumbling about?
I can't understand you!
Oh my god!
This doesn't seem very fair.
What's happening?
What is happening?
Turn on!
Wait,
how do I move?
Down!
Left!
How do I move?
Left stick?
I'm using it, but it's not working!
Wait, my left stick is not working, you guys.
My stick is not...
My actual controller is not working.
It's not working.
My stick is not working.
Oh, it's D-pad.
It's D-pad.
Right!
OK.
It scared me.
What do I do?
Damn it, I missed it.
Where is hers?
I can't see hers.
Oh jeez, there's so many.
Right!
Lower!
Down!
Left!
Oh shoot!
Those were mine.
I should have gotten those.
That's my bad.
Can we get him now?
Oh my gosh.
Right!
This is so hard.
Oh my gosh.
Down!
Down
his ass!
A little bit.
Right!
Middle!
Left!
Oh my god.
Oh shoot.
OK.
This could be worse I suppose.
This is such a bizarre fight.
I'm not gonna lie.
Left!
Oh shoot.
Did that hurt us?
I don't know actually.
No.
Right!
Up!
Left!
Oh my god.
This is kinda slow.
I don't think I like this very much.
It's like slow and weird.
I don't like it.
And we are already half health.
Oh my gosh.
Down!
Right!
Oh my god.
We missed our chance.
I can't use a heal pack.
Heal!
Recover!
Oh actually.
Down!
Left!
Oh OK.
You got it.
Nice.
Good job girl.
I got it.
I wish she would use her own eyes but you know.
I ask for so much in this game don't I?
Down!
Right!
Oh I think they are getting tougher maybe.
Oh he is only half way.
And we are close to dying actually.
Oh let me get these.
Down!
Right!
Left!
Did I hit him at all?
I don't think I did.
It sucks!
Oh I
have to go through all of that again.
I have to go through all of those cutscenes.
All over again.
Wow
Wow Wow
Exit How much of the play time is repeating cutscenes?
Oh my gosh.
This was like 15 minutes of cutscene I feel.
No way.
I can't talk.
It won't let me.
Where?
Did she die already?
I guess so.
We are going to go to...
Run
Yup that did much of a difference.
Oh man.
Are you kidding me right now?
Hold on I am going to read the game facts and see if there is a cheat.
They don't deal much damage to you even if they hit you.
I think they do deal a bit of damage.
That's how we died from those.
I am going to go to the bathroom real quick guys.
I'll be right back.
I might do a save state.
I am not going to lie.
I wonder if I should just do a save state.
That's the real cheating baby.
Sheesha
Okay I'll do one.
I'll do one once we get to the final boss.
I'll be right back.
We'll blow up the station and these stones before they can be used on earth.
Wait for me.
I'll be right there.
This is it.
The monitor room.
There is no mistake.
I finally made it.
You are inside of here.
Hi.
Can you see me?
Yeah.
It's okay.
It doesn't matter if you can't see me on camera.
You'll see me soon enough.
Is it alright if I come in?
Why does it look... Yes.
Alright.
Wow.
My pulse is pounding.
Even though I don't have a heart.
Where do you think you are going?
Thanks for the 5 gifted.
I'm going to go get some more water too.
Sorry.
I only went to the bathroom.
I'm going to go get some more water.
We're almost done guys.
We got this.
Just one last fight and then the end.
One more fight.
Oh, water.
You became a monster long ago.
You liar.
Believe me.
I will save you.
You too.
You'll become dust here.
Become dust?
The only thing that's becoming dust is you.
How dare you, you bloody whore.
Bitch, you're dead.
I'm going to crush the life out of you.
I'm not getting away.
I'm not getting away with this.
L2 allows you to skip?
L1, L2, R2, R1.
Nope, nothing let me skip.
I'm holding down L2.
Nope, nothing.
Go diagonal.
Can I say that?
Like upper left, lower right?
Instead of just saying left, like left, down.
Can I say upper left?
Can I do that?
I can?
Oh, ok, ok, ok.
She did it once accidentally.
Oh, ok, ok, ok, ok.
Cool, cool, cool, cool.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm holding L1.
Nah, still no.
Boo!
Still, yeah.
R1, R2, L2, L1.
Nope.
Have you tried saying skip?
Skip!
L3.
Nope.
Oh yeah, the save state.
Let's do it right here.
Save state.
Save.
Yeah!
Ok.
We saved it right here.
L4, L5, L6.
Oh, little girl, hold on.
She wanted in her bed.
There you go, baby girl.
A little princess.
I never claimed that this was real hardware.
Sorry, I don't actually own this game.
But also, it would have been very difficult to play with the mic setup and everything.
Maybe I should have done a save state.
Let's do, like, once we're really ready to start.
Ok, 2.
There we go.
Boo!
Ok.
Alright, cool, cool, cool.
I'm on.
I'm turned on.
There we go.
Alright, I'm turned on.
Ok.
There we are.
Very good.
Left!
Right!
At least they go one side at a time, which is not so bad.
Why are you guys blushing?
Is it because you like the monster man?
It's no
good!
Ok.
Upper right!
Down!
Left!
Oh my god.
Up!
Girl, seriously?
You're gonna be like that right now.
You better, you better, you better not.
Ugh.
Bottom right!
Down!
Oh my gosh.
Never mind.
Left!
Down!
Oh, that's me, that's me.
Oh shit, that's my bad.
Oh, I hate the depth perception on this, you guys.
Oh, the depth perception is really gonna kick my ass here.
Oh, sorry.
Upper right!
Right!
Ok.
Oh, that's me.
And it's so hard to see them too, when he like summons them.
It's so hard to see.
Bottom right!
Left!
What the hell?
Kill that thing?
There we go.
The depth perception is so bad here.
Holy moly.
I am struggling a whole lot.
Right!
Left!
Ok, I think he's about to summon.
Bottom right!
Down!
Right!
I'm too slow!
Left!
Bottom right!
Oh my gosh, wait, me too.
I think I should just reload.
Try saying lower right.
Up!
Left!
Oh, I think I should just reload at this point.
Right!
Oh my god.
I forgot what it's like to play a game.
Lower right!
Don't know my left from my right!
Oh wait, that's me.
Down!
We got that.
Oh yeah.
Lower right!
Ok, ok, not bad.
Right!
Ok.
Left!
Ok, ok.
I got it, I got it.
Maybe.
Where are they coming from?
Down!
Right!
Damn it.
Holy moly.
Just one more try maybe.
As long as I don't get hit.
Left!
Down!
Lower left!
So close!
I'm getting the hang of it.
Operator!
Let's go!
Use the left thruster to attack.
Again!
Where should I aim?
Tell me up, down, left, right.
Ok!
Let's go!
And I didn't use safe spaces the entire time.
Left!
Upper left!
No, down!
Down!
Right!
It's
only to avoid the cutscenes honestly.
Otherwise I would have been fine with doing it, you know, but...
Yeah.
Left!
Help me out a little.
Right!
Down!
Up!
I can't tell.
That works, yeah.
Is that hitting him when she does it?
I don't know actually.
I don't think so.
Right!
Ok.
Upper right!
Has to be the left positioning?
Ok.
It's ok.
Right!
Oh shoot.
Left!
Up!
Ok, nice!
Nice, nice, nice.
Right!
Down!
Left?
Right?
Where is it?
Oh, nice, nice, nice!
Holy!
Upper right!
Oh, me too, me too.
Sorry.
Alright.
Left!
Down!
Right!
Oh, we missed it.
Dang it, it's ok.
Up!
Did I get out?
Right!
There we go.
Oh my gosh!
I'm so stressed right now!
It's not even that hard!
Left!
Up!
Oh dammit, I should have gotten that one.
I didn't realize it was...
Bottom right!
No, bottom right!
Down!
We have to avoid him doing the...
Up!
Left!
Oh, nevermind.
You missed it, you missed it.
You missed it.
It's fine though.
It's cool.
Don't worry about it.
Right!
Lower right!
Down!
Left!
Right!
Oh my gosh, are we gonna miss it?
No!
Up!
Ok, nevermind.
That went to me.
Ok.
Right!
Nice.
Left!
Down!
Ok.
Up!
Left!
Wait!
Oh we got him!
My throat is so gone.
Oh gosh guys.
Sorry, I couldn't check chat at all.
Literally not even a single time.
Oh my gosh.
We did it!
I almost did the load state, I'm not gonna lie.
It's me, the worm!
There's only the two of us left now.
Let me borrow your seat for a moment.
Ok.
Would she love you if you were a worm?
I have like pustules all over my body cause I'm poisoned.
It's still warm.
And sticky from your wormy body.
Ok.
What's wrong?
What?
You did that.
What are we waiting for?
What is it?
Yeah?
Oh no!
Ok, you can do it yourself then.
Oh, escape hatch.
Security level A.
Open!
Oh, open.
Oh, she's doing it.
It's not me this time.
Password.
My frigid heart.
The only thing that melts it is...
just your...
Please operator, I need your help one last time.
Please tell me the password to the escape hatch.
Is it worm?
I don't know.
Hold on.
Sorry.
I'm checking game facts right now.
The one thing that melts it is your worm.
What is it?
Worm.
No, I said worm.
Mint.
Touch, that's five letters.
Worm!
Oh!
Love.
The only thing that melts it is...
just your love.
Ok, got it.
Not the mic change.
Your hate.
It's your love!
Bye!
Guess what we have here.
It's some leaves.
Some leaves that I got my child.
Sir!
This way!
Oh, sorry.
I forgot to turn it off.
What happened?
Oh!
Get out!
I think at this point there is like...
space coming in.
There is like non-oxygen in the spaceship.
Take a deep breath!
Mission accomplished.
Oh, I thought that was me for a second.
I was about to be like, I'm hot!
Holy shit!
That's me!
I'm the ultimate self insert character.
They won't even let me see a little bit of my body.
I'm a self insert!
Bye dad.
I'm a worm.
I'm not a worm.
Our girlfriend!
She was so...
She was so cute.
Not gonna lie, she did kind of look like Metal Gear Naomi, but...
We forgive her.
We did it!
The GIF explosions.
What do you mean one last thing?
Are we not gonna talk more?
I look like
a Roblox character from behind.
No way!
Space.
This is so beautiful.
Oh my god!
Those didn't dissolve in the explosion?
That's not good.
She never learned your name.
She really didn't.
Were they planning on a sequel?
I wonder.
What is this like Final Fantasy-esque music?
I like it though.
Everybody died, except us.
We completed Lifeline!
I said I would do it today.
We did it!
Two survivors out of 50.
She was awesome!
Wait, no that's the reporter.
Just kidding.
No, the wife of the Prime Minister.
Love that lady.
She was great.
There are so many characters that just like were there and then faded out of existence.
Like Gino.
Gino was supposed to be our love interest.
Revolver Ocelot.
Time for New Game Plus with the new outfits.
I am curious to see what the outfit looks like.
Do I start off with the outfit?
We gave Gino brain damage, so he might have not survived anyway.
Do a speedrun of it.
I want to know what is the world record for this game.
I'm going to look it up.
I apologize for using the save state in the final boss, you guys.
I apologize.
Good job for pushing through and having the restraint of not using save state until the very last moment just to skip the cutscenes.
I honestly just wanted to save time for all of us.
I don't want to waste your time.
Congrats on beating your 7th game.
I think this year you are stronger than me for sure.
I would have not been able to complete this.
Good gaming and perseverance, Mindo.
Thank you!
You didn't use it for gameplay purposes.
It's cool.
Okay, thank you.
Thanks for understanding.
I don't like... Well, you know, I've used him before.
Like...
Oh my god, at an angle she looks like Raiden.
Congrats on beating the game.
Which was more frustrating to play, this or Yomawari's final boss.
I feel like I should... Well, I don't know.
I feel like I should go through Yomawari again and see how much of a gamer I've become.
But, this is the most frustrating thing about this game.
Usually with games, I can feel like...
Yeah, I...
Even if a part...
Operator is me!
But I can feel like even if I get through a difficult part of a game, I am honing my skills as a gamer.
With this, I don't feel like I learned anything.
I truly don't feel like I...
I didn't... I didn't gain any sort of knowledge or skill from this game.
Speedruns between 2 and a half hours at number 1 and 3 hours at number 7.
Upload your run to be number 9?
That's not bad.
Hayden, thank you for the 5 gifted.
Chidoto, welcome back.
Never a waste of time with you, Minto.
Chocolate fudge face, thank you for the super chat.
If only they'd known the stone would have sown such lethal evil in people.
If only, right?
And you know what's also so frustrating?
We didn't need that final heal.
We didn't even need it.
Is the bosses... Wait, this boss...
VA's Chad Virgil... Wait, really?
You became a master tongue twister.
That's true?
That is very true.
Why did it have that heal at the end?
Right!
Strange.
Thanks for the ping!
Congrats on beating one of the most frustrating games I've ever seen.
The craziness in the last 2 hours almost made up for the suffering.
God gamer Minto.
The story was pretty wild.
I liked that.
I did not expect a philosopher's stone and then for...
All that happened.
So fun.
It got pretty bonkers.
The brain...
I'm gonna die if you don't think of something quick!
I'm gonna die!
One last remix!
Test it!
Second game you've completed this month involving a stone?
Sonic?
Oh,
Indiana Jones!
Think of something quick!
Quick!
Number 2!
In her mouth, Rio!
Dodge, right, Rio!
Number 2!
In her mouth!
Dodge, Rio!
Number 2!
In her mouth!
Quick!
Rest in glitch face.
Thank you for the 10 gifted.
Let's see.
I'll try.
Load game.
New game plus.
I'll see the sexy outfit.
I'm obviously not gonna wait for the second, second sexy outfit.
Because that's way far in the game.
But we will see her...
Her sexy outfit.
For you guys.
We'll see her sexy outfit for you guys.
I am a ghost of the people.
We can look it up.
Surprisingly, it was hard for me to find screenshots of this game.
To use for like backgrounds and stuff.
Just image search.
Second.
Ok, hold on.
Can I skip this?
L1.
Oh wait!
We get like new...
We get new context.
They did talk about this at the beginning.
And all the stuff...
Is this from the...
I completely forgot about this at the beginning.
Googling sexy outfit.
I don't get like anything.
Sucks.
I only see her waitress outfit.
Guys, I have people messaging me for collabs.
I'm playing a nostalgic game.
I just finished it.
I cleared it.
Our popular ghost.
Popular.
Lifeline outfits PS2 got some image.
Oh really?
Wait!
Don't spoil!
Don't spoil for you!
Lifeline.
Don't spoil.
Don't spoil for yourself.
I keep getting Lifeline from Apex.
I see it.
New game plus Gustav's room final boss.
I suffered with that more than I did anything else in this game.
What's wrong with me?
Why do I have such a yearning for dirt?
I want to eat dirt.
Dirt.
Dirt because I'm a worm?
I want to eat dirt.
Oh, thanks for the food.
Gosh, I'm a worm right now.
I'm a worm.
Our wound.
Wait, what about the poison?
Do we get healed or...
Thanks for the rain.
I'm a worm.
I want to eat dirt.
Dirt.
Wait, do we see her walking around?
Bark like a dog.
This is the opening party a little while ago.
No, I see that person in their regular waitress outfit.
Murphy, thanks for the baguette.
Baguette.
Sure see, thank you for the baguette.
We were lucky to be invited to the space station hotel.
Why were we there?
Our girlfriend.
Oh, that's not a sexy outfit.
I mean, yes, but it's not the sexiest.
It's not a new sex...
Girlfriend Naomi.
StarCreator, thanks for the baguette.
Naomi.
Cashew, thank you for the baguette.
Thank you so much.
I hope you had a good stream.
Jay, thank you for the baguette.
We're just going through the... We just beat the game.
We're just going through the beginning again because you get a new game plus outfit.
That's sex?
What are those?
We definitely did not have to fight anything like that.
Thank god.
Oh, just kidding.
Yeah, we did.
Yeah, we fought that.
Nevermind.
Oh, we fought that.
Yeah.
Shoot it in the middle eye!
Left eye!
Right eye!
Middle eye!
Red eye!
I'm going to be hearing these comments for like a millennia.
I'm never going to forget.
In her mouth!
I'd rather not!
Thanks for the five gifted.
I passed out.
I can't believe we're spending Christmas in space.
Thank you.
Guys, this year should we spend Christmas in space?
My beloved girlfriend...
Last time we'll see her.
Yeah, what do you do for Christmas in space?
Yeah, this was a Christmas... Wait.
Where's your new outfit?
What?
Oh my God!
Got the tattoo.
Sex?
No!
I got you.
God damn!
Mario!
Does she still have her commands?
Does she still have her old commands?
Holy moly!
Are you trapped inside that monitor room?
So we share the same dilemma.
I want to know what the other outfit is.
First there's something I have to get.
What is the other outfit?
She's got her grippers on display.
This is too much!
The tattoo is also way too much.
The rose tattoo?
What is she, a biker?
The single glove.
I want to know what the other outfit is.
I have space trauma.
My oshi left us to travel the stars.
Oh no!
Other outfit is more beamed.
Yes, I'm beamed!
How can I find it?
I want to show you guys.
I want to find it.
That's her shooting glove.
Lifeline.
PS2 outfit.
Oh!
Wait!
I think I see a little bit of it.
Hold on.
I'll save this picture.
Welcome!
I'm trying to see if I can find a better picture.
Scanning the internet.
I'm hacking the hard drives.
Look at this.
This is the...
I can't
do this anymore.
I don't want to...
No, no.
That's it.
That's it for that.
No, we're not playing the game again.
We're not playing the game again.
Wait, but the sexy pose.
Okay, we must figure out if she can do a sexy pose.
Right eye.
Middle eye.
Left eye.
Never change real.
Red eye.
I found a YouTube title.
Lifeline PS2 part 26 bonus.
No way.
Yeah, I know.
She got the pink toes.
And your voice.
I remember now.
You were at the party.
I think you were the youngest couple there.
Weren't you?
You were with the girl in the dark blue dress.
Can't read, can't aim, no sense of direction, never change real.
What was her name?
Oh, what was her name?
What was her name, you guys?
Joe Mama.
That can't be true.
What's your girlfriend's name?
Your mom.
Minky.
Brand new look, same great real.
She was polite.
I said Nimi Nightmare before.
Naked Snake.
Vicky.
Amy.
The Hedgehog.
Kiara.
Rio.
How do you know it?
Say Kristen.
Kristen.
Is that like her voice actress's name?
Is that her voice actress's name?
Ever since Phantom Thief you became my OCN, I'm a big fan.
I want to announce to you that my family is having another whisp of the Phantom House.
I'm going to be a brother for a seventh time.
That's a full house.
Thank you so much.
Thank you for the super chat.
Congratulations.
Is that her VA's name?
Cool.
Elizabeth.
Amanda.
No, that's not it.
It was three syllables.
She's very polite.
What is her name?
Do you guys know that meme where it's a little girl and her mom is like, who are you playing with sweetie?
And she's like, Amanda.
And then it shows a grown ass man.
And the mom's like, oh!
And he goes, hi, I'm Amanda.
And I'm six.
That's how she says Amanda.
That's what it reminds me of.
Amanda.
Sexy pose.
No.
No, that's not it.
It was three syllables.
Three syllables.
What's the name of that girl?
Joe Mama.
Sharon.
No, that's not it.
It was three syllables.
How many names are in here?
Gustav.
Jonathan.
Oh, you accepted the video.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, I give up.
Madonna.
Naomi.
What?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
She's donezo, probably.
Thank you for the link!
Copy.
You might hear it real quick.
Sorry if you do.
Oh, what the hell?
Oh, copy link.
Oh man.
No.
I'll find your Naomi.
Is she talking to me?
Nah.
Where's the...
When did she change outfits?
Trying to find it.
Wait, did I find a good picture?
Oh, wow!
Okay, hold on.
I'll show you guys.
Okay.
Sorry, I just want to see if she can do the sexy pose.
I don't want to play anymore.
I don't want to play anymore!
I've played these games before!
Please let me be free!
What did she say?
Yeah.
I don't know what she asked me.
Okay.
I just want to see if you can sexy pose.
Got it.
Stop yapping at me.
I will.
Oh my god.
Consultation.
She's so proud of me.
Okay.
It's not really a password, no.
She means that.
She...
She's so serious.
Okay, please!
Let me free!
Okay.
Yes.
Sexy pose.
Okay, bye Rio.
Bye bye.
Bye Rio.
Bye.
Bye bye.
Okay, give me one second you guys.
Give me one second to pull up the YouTube and I'll show you guys a little bit of her other outfit.
Since we're not doing it.
Since I don't wanna.
You can't make me.
Okay, I'll even keep the person's channel up.
You know, since I'm borrowing from them.
Okay.
Look at that.
Look, this video has less than 300 views.
Wait, it's only from a month ago.
Who was playing this in 20...
Well, I guess it kinda like popped off again, right?
Recently.
Wait, do we have to listen...
Do we hear this person's voice?
Oh wait, I don't really wanna hear their voice.
Damn, look at the pants!
Oh my god!
I kinda love it.
Okay.
Alright guys.
Nice!
We beat Lifeline!
Thank you guys for a fun adventure in space.
That was a little stressful.
But it was still fun.
And I hope you guys had fun too.
And I'm finally gonna go eat dinner.
But I've been...
I've been munching on corn.
So, yay!
Yay!
Try Princess, thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Otsumito everybody!
Have a great day, have a great night, have a great morning, have a great afternoon, have a great...
Whatever time it is for you.
I'll haunt you later.
Itterasshai!
Bye bye!
Good night, good night, good night!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Bye bye!